This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人。你有帮助真正改变的渴望吗？拉西特学院为你提供“依赖与老年护理”项目。获取这些能力
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
对于陪伴和支持面临健康和依赖问题的人至关重要。建设一份丰富多彩的职业生涯，服务于全国各地的法语社群。不用担心法语水平，在
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
拉西特学院，这一切皆有可能。今天就访问CollegeLaCite.com。这是加拿大国家健康培训联盟的一项倡议，
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
由加拿大卫生部支持。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓坏了。恶魔，醒醒。我是那个目睹了
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
克里瓦奇和德皮波谋杀案发生的人。安东尼·德皮波毫无悔意，在被判处最高刑罚时显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我要把这带进坟墓。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方，收听《骨谷》（Bone Valley）的《魔鬼采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
快乐至关重要，它也难以捉摸，但现在有一种全新且令人兴奋的方式，可以开启你的旅程，
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
走向一个更加快乐的生活。《快乐101》（Joy 101）。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotb）主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的现场聊天。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“Joy 101”并立即收听。由CVS呈现的《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
每个人都把我当成一名足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与自我出生以来的种种问题、错误、人际关系和情感共处。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。这只是一些关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯（Javier "Chicharito" Hernández），
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets.
请在iHeartRadio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。你的丈夫并非你所想的那样。你的身体并非你原本以为的那样。你的身份是由一段秘密历史塑造的。我是丹妮·夏皮罗（Dani Shapiro）。而这些只是我将在《家族秘密》（Family Secrets）第14季中探索的众多震撼人心的故事中的冰山一角。
He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to Season 14 of Family Secrets. Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
他有点把我推开，说：“让开。”然后他走出了前门，跳上一辆车开走了。那是最后一次见到他。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《家族秘密》第14季。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, I have such a special guest episode for you. One that goes places we've never been before on the podcast. We are talking to somebody who has spent most of her life navigating a chronic illness. being in the public eye, and just learning how to exist in a world that can be very cruel to people who look different. She was diagnosed just six years old with a rare medical condition. Her story is one of amazing power, resilience, creativity. You may know her from her modeling work, her advocacy,
很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析的是我们20多岁的心理学。今天，我为你准备了一期非常特别的嘉宾访谈节目。这一集将带我们去到本播客从未涉足的领域。我们的访谈对象大半生都在与慢性病抗争、身处公众视线之中，并学习如何在对长相不同的人非常残酷的世界中生存。她六岁时就被诊断出患有一种罕见的医疗疾病。她的故事充满了惊人的力量、韧性和创造力。你可能通过她的模特工作、维权活动认识她，
her behind the scenes content at the Oscars on runways, film premieres, amongst many other things. Welcome to the podcast, Nikki Lilly. Thank you. I was just like, Like that was the most incredible intro. Really? That was amazing. Okay, I honestly, thank you for saying that because I always like to make sure our intros just cover every amazing dimension of somebody. You did.
她在奥斯卡颁奖典礼幕后、T台上、电影首映式上的内容，以及许多其他事情。欢迎来到本播客，尼基·莉莉（Nikki Lilly）。谢谢你。我当时就想，那简直是最不可思议的开场白。真的吗？太棒了。好吧，说实话，谢谢你这么说，因为我总是希望确保我们的开场白能够涵盖一个人所有精彩的维度。你做到了。
That was incredible. Thank you so much for having me. I was just saying to you before we started, I've been a fan of yours for so long. So this feels insane. Oh my God. And the fact that you found me on Substack is crazy. No. No, honestly, as soon as I joined Substack,
那太不可思议了。非常感谢邀请我。我刚才在开始录制前就对你说过，我一直是你的超级粉丝。所以这感觉太疯狂了。天哪。而且你竟然在Substack上找到了我，这太疯狂了。不。不，说实话，当我一加入Substack时，
just as like someone that wanted to get more into reading and is really introspective and an overthinker, I was like, okay, I need to go to substack. And your substacks were literally the first thing I was recommended. So it was meant to be. I think it was. And now you're on the pod. Yeah. Full circle.
只是作为一个想要更多地阅读、非常内省且有点过度思考的人，我就想，好吧，我需要去Substack。而你的Substack文章字面意思上就是推荐给我的第一样东西。所以这就是命中注定。我想是的。现在你来到播客了。是的。兜了一个大圈。
What can you say? I know. Well, full circle, but like in the opposite direction where I feel like, this is what most people know me for. And the fact that you found me on my substack where like I'm a little bit more vulnerable. No, I love it. Yeah. That means a lot.
你能说什么呢？我知道。好吧，兜了个大圈，但就像是朝着相反的方向，我觉得，大多数人都是因为这个才认识我的。而你竟然在我的Substack上找到了我，在那里我表现得更脆弱一些。不，我很喜欢。是的。这对我意义重大。
I always forget to get people to introduce themselves. I always just jump into the question. No, same. Same. Briefly introduce yourself. Who are you? How do most people, how might people know who you are already? So I'm Nikki. Most people know me as Nikki Lilly Online. And I started making videos, like you said, around eight years old.
我总是忘记让人家做自我介绍。我总是直接切入问题。不，我也是。一样。简单介绍一下你自己。你是谁？大家通常、或者人们可能已经怎么知道你是谁的？所以我是尼基。大多数人在网上都知道我是尼基·莉莉。正如你所说，我大约八岁开始制作视频。
And it all came from me being diagnosed with a condition called AVM at 6. And I was a super active, chatty, outgoing child, had to give up all of the things I loved that made me happy as a 6 year old. And my life was very empty. It was very lonely. And so YouTube became a way for me to connect to the outside world. And so I would watch videos from my hospital bed and almost felt like I was friends with these people I was watching for like 20 minutes. I could escape from treatments or hospital monitor sounds or whatever it was. And so one day I asked my mum and dad if I'd be allowed to post a video on YouTube.
这一切都源于我6岁时被诊断出患有一种叫做AVM（动静脉畸形）的疾病。我曾经是一个超级活跃、爱聊天、外向的孩子，却不得不放弃所有我热爱的事物，那些作为一个6岁小孩能让我感到快乐的事物。我的生活非常空虚。非常孤独。因此，YouTube成了我连接外部世界的途径。于是我会从病床上看视频，感觉就像我和这些我看了20分钟视频的人成了朋友。我可以逃离治疗、医院监视器的声音，或者无论那是什么声音。所以有一天我问爸爸妈妈，我是否可以被允许在YouTube上发一段视频。
And they're obviously apprehensive. Looking back, me being eight years old is actually insane. But I think they understood it was like the exception to the rule. because I needed something. And so it became my project for myself, something to put my energy into that was mine that helped me regain control and to focus on outside of what I was doing.
他们显然心存顾虑。回想起来，我当时八岁其实挺疯狂的。但我认为他们明白这就像是个打破常规的特例，因为我需要点寄托。于是这成了我自己的项目，一个可以倾注精力的东西，是属于我自己的东西，它帮我重新夺回了控制权，让我把注意力从我正在经历的事情转移到外部。
So that happened when I was eight years old and now I'm 21 and since then I've done advocacy work, I've spoken at the United Nations. A lot of my, it's funny because when I first started making videos, I didn't address my condition at all for like three years. It was just kind of like a world in which I wanted wanted to exist without my condition being a factor because it had taken up every part of my real life. And so it was just me sharing my love of makeup and like, you know, baking and things that I
所以这一切发生在我八岁的时候，现在我21岁了。从那以后，我做过维权工作，在联合国发过言。很多时候，有趣的是，当我刚开始做视频的时候，我有大约三年时间完全没有提及我的病情。它更像是一个我想象中的世界，在这个世界里，我希望我的病情不是一个影响因素，因为它已经占据了我现实生活中的每一部分。所以这只是我分享我对化妆的热爱，以及，你知道的，烘焙和一些事情，
was finding as I was diagnosed to put my energy into my time into. And so that's kind of how it all began. It was not something where it like boomed from the beginning. But as I posted more on YouTube, I started to gain a following and started to do some work on TV. And now I'm here. That was like the longest intro to myself ever. That was not short at all. Oh, I think that was, I feel like there's a lot more that you could answer. Yeah, I know. And I was like, let me just stop now. Yeah. Don't worry. I've got a lot of follow-ups. Yeah. First follow-up, what YouTubers did you watch before you started posting? Do you remember? Oh my God. Of course. It was like Zoella. Classic.
那是我在确诊后发现的，用来投入我的精力和时间的东西。所以事情差不多就是这样开始的。它并不是那种从一开始就爆火的东西。但随着我在YouTube上发布更多内容，我开始积累粉丝，并开始在电视上做一些工作。现在我来到这里了。那简直是有史以来最长的一段自我介绍。一点也不短。哦，我觉得那是，我觉得你还可以回答更多。是的，我知道。我当时就想，让我现在就停下来吧。是的。别担心。我有很多后续问题。是的。第一个后续问题，你在开始发布视频之前看过哪些YouTuber？你还记得吗？天哪。当然。就像索埃拉（Zoella）一样。经典。
Like all of the brick crew, they call it. So it was like Zoella, Alfie, Tanya Burr. Tanya Baer's a funny one because I recently, like, well, actually a couple of years ago, met her. We were in the queue for the same event. And you have to like queue up for the carpet. And she started talking to me first. And in my head, all I could think was, oh my gosh, little Nikki would be dying right now.
就像他们所说的整个英国网红圈（brick crew）。所以就像索埃拉、阿尔菲（Alfie）、坦娅·伯尔（Tanya Burr）。坦娅·伯尔很有意思，因为我最近，呃，其实是几年前，遇到过她。我们在同一个活动的队伍里。你得排队走红毯。她先开始和我说话。而在我的脑海里，我能想到的只有，哦天哪，小尼基现在看到这个肯定激动得要命。
Like I bought her makeup line. Like literally that whole group was obsessed with them. And so we talked for like 20 minutes. I didn't actually even tell her my name. We were just talking. And then she kind of left. And then I didn't see her and she'd followed me, like, straight away after. And you were like, oh, my goodness.
就像我买过她的彩妆系列一样。字面意思上，我对整个那个群体都着迷。所以我们聊了大约20分钟。我甚至没有告诉她我的名字。我们只是在聊天。然后她就离开了。我没再见到她，她随后立刻就关注了我。你当时就想，哦，我的天哪。
No, honestly, especially when, I'm sure you feel that same way, when something happens that you know your younger self would just die over, it's the most full circle thing. So I would watch them. I also would watch a lot of like American beauty gurus. Bethany Motor. Oh my God. Bethany Moter, Michelle Fam.
不，说实话，尤其是当——我相信你也有同感——当发生某些事情，你知道年轻时的自己会为此激动得发狂时，这是最完美的圆满结局。所以我经常看他们的视频。我也看很多美国的美丽博主。贝瑟尼·莫塔（Bethany Mota）。哦天哪。贝瑟尼·莫塔，米歇尔·潘（Michelle Phan）。
Yeah. Like Hila Oakley, Joe Grissette. Like all of that group, Trois Savan before he was like to sing a Trois Savan. No, literally all of them, I was just obsessed. I'd watch like all of their vlogs at VidCon. Yeah. And it would be like, you know what I remember. Oh my God.
是的。像希拉·奥克利（Hilary Duff? Hla Oakley）、乔·格里塞特（Joe Sugg? 译者按：发音近似，保持原意）。就像那个群体里的所有人，特洛伊·希文（Troye Sivan）在他成为“歌手特洛伊·希文”之前。不，字面意思上，他们所有人，我都迷得不行。我会在VidCon看他们所有的Vlog。是的。然后就会像，你知道我记得什么吗。哦天哪。
We had actually Arden Rose. I don't know if you know who there is on the podcast the other day. And we were talking about how like you would watch the same video by like seven different people and it was literally just the same blog of the same stuff. Just different angles. And you'd be like, load them up and you'd be like, and that one next. And like before you go to school. I was like actually the best.
前几天我们其实在播客里请到了阿登·罗斯（Arden Rose）。我不知道你知不知道那是谁。我们当时在讨论，你可能会看七个不同的人拍的同一个视频，它字面意思上就是同一堆东西的同一个Vlog。只是角度不同。你会想，加载那个，然后你会想，接下来是那个。就像在上学之前一样。我当时觉得那简直是太棒了。
I was obsessed. Especially with Zoella, I remember doing like reviews of her new like collections on my YouTube channel. When you were on YouTube. I was so obsessed with her. Huge full circle. Yeah. Let's talk about AVM. Yeah.
我太着迷了。尤其是对索埃拉，我记得曾在我的YouTube频道上做过她新系列的测评。当你在YouTube上的时候。我太迷她了。巨大的圆满结局。是的。我们来谈谈AVM（动静脉畸形）吧。是的。
Can you talk about what it's like to have it but also for people who may not know what it is? What's a little brief overview that they could understand? Yeah. So I was born with my AVM and you have to be born with an AVM, but it can become active at any age. So someone could live up until 21, which is my age now, and then it could be triggered. And until then, never know they have it, never have any signs, never really show up on scans unless they were kind of looking for it. And so till I was six years old, both sides of my face looked the exact same. There was no inkling that there was anything wrong with me.
你能谈谈患有这种病是什么感觉，而且对于可能不知道它是什么的人来说，能做一个简短的概述让他们理解吗？好的。我生来就患有AVM，你必须生来就有AVM，但它可以在任何年龄被激活。所以一个人可以活到21岁——也就是我现在的年龄——然后它被触发。在此之前，可能从不知道自己有病，没有任何迹象，除非专门去寻找，否则在扫描中也显现不出来。所以在我6岁之前，我脸的两边长得一模一样。没有任何迹象表明我有任何问题。
And then at six years old, I started having veins and sweating appearing on the right side of my face. Didn't know what it was. I didn't think much of it, but we went to the doctor. the doctor very quickly referred me to another doctor and then ensued a bunch of tests and scans and just hospital stuff and appointments. And then after a couple of months, it was very quick turnaround because everyone was kind of like what is going on. I was told with my parents sat in kind of a dingy hospital room that I had in AVM. So an AVM is basically an abnormal connection between your arteries and your veins.
然后在6岁时，我脸的右侧开始出现血管和肿胀。不知道那是什么。我没想那么多，但我们去了医生那儿。医生很快把我转诊给另一位医生，接着就是一连串的检查、扫描、各种医院的事情和预约。几个月后，这个转变非常快，因为每个人都在想这到底是怎么回事。我和父母坐在一间昏暗的医院病房里，被告知我患有AVM。所以AVM基本上就是你的动脉和静脉之间存在一种异常连接。
So all over your body you have arteries, veins and capillaries. And capillaries go in between your arteries and veins to balance out the high and low flow pressures between them. But when you have an AVM, your capillaries basically aren't formed in the places that they need to be. So your arteries and veins collide directly into each other and tangle. So it's an abnormal connection. And because of that, there's a buildup of pressure from the blood vessels, which causes pain, swelling, appearance of veins, but also the worth part for me and people with AVMs is bleating. So you can have life-threatening bleeds because of the build-up of pressure.
所以在你全身都有动脉、静脉和毛细血管。而毛细血管穿行于动脉和静脉之间，以平衡它们之间的高压和低压血流。但当你患有AVM时，毛细血管基本上没有在需要它们的地方形成。所以你的动脉和静脉直接碰撞并缠绕在一起。因此这是一种异常连接。正因为如此，血管中会产生压力积聚，从而导致疼痛、肿胀、血管显现，但对我以及其他AVM患者来说最糟糕的部分是出血。由于压力积聚，你可能会发生危及生命的出血。
It's almost like a pressure cooker where like there can be a build-off of pressure, then that blood vessel is just ready to go. And then you can have like a really bad bleed. So I was in a coma when I was 13 because of, yeah, for eight days because of the bleed so bad. Yeah. So I've had a lot of like near-death experiences. And I think that's what's crazy is I think a lot of people on social media. I mean, if you followed me for a while, you'll know kind of as much as you can,
它有点像一个高压锅，压力会不断积聚，然后那个血管就随时准备爆裂。接着你就会发生非常严重的出血。所以我在13岁时曾因——是的，因为出血太严重而昏迷了八天。是的。所以我经历过很多次濒死体验。我觉得疯狂的是，我认为社交媒体上的很多人。我的意思是，如果你关注我一段时间，你就会在最大可能范围内了解到，
the depth of what I've been through, like, physically. But a lot of people just know me from my appearance and not, like, the physical side. Because I share it, but I don't. You know, I'm not, like, pulling my phone out when I'm in the emergency room or I'm in a hospital appointment. So what they see is more me talking about, like, my appearance versus the physical side that affects me, you know, day to day. Like, I, every Wednesday or every other Wednesday have to go and see my nose doctor so he can check if there's any blood vessels that need to be, you know, treated so that I don't. then start having a bleed. So it's always, you never feel like you're stable.
我所经历的身体上的痛苦有多深。但很多人只通过我的外表认识我，而不是通过身体层面。因为我分享这些，但我又没有。你知道的，我不会在急诊室或者去医院复诊时掏出手机拍照。所以他们看到的更多是我在谈论我的外表，而不是那些日复一日影响着我的身体层面。比如我，每个星期三或者每隔一个星期三都得去看我的鼻科医生，这样他才能检查是否有任何血管需要接受治疗，你知道的，这样我就不会
There's no sense of stability when you have an AVM and currently there's no cure. Everything's kind of trials or I've been on three trial drugs. None of them work for me. I've had 98 surgeries to just try and maintain my symptoms for four years. Me and my parents use their savings to get me treatment in America for four years every six to eight weeks. So my life has kind of become about like treat and repeat and hospital. And when I was younger, especially hospital, we talked about it as if it was my second home. And I've always kind of struggled a lot with like my relationship with my body because from a very early age,
开始出血。所以总是这样，你永远不会觉得自己是稳定的。当你患有AVM时，根本没有安全感可言，而且目前还没有治愈的方法。一切都算是试验，我尝试过三种试验性药物。对我都没有用。我做过98次手术，只为了维持症状四年。我和父母用他们的积蓄让我在美国每隔6到8周接受一次治疗，持续了四年。所以我的生活基本上变成了治疗、重复和医院。当我小的时候，尤其是医院，我们谈论它就像它是我的第二个家。而且我一直很难处理好我和自己身体的关系，因为从很小的时候起，
it's kind of given over to doctors and stitched up, cut into, it didn't feel like mine. So for a lot of my life, I haven't really had autonomy over my body. my body, which has been a really hard thing because I think when you're younger, like, you know, you're trying to find yourself and find who you are and have a sense of self and identity. So when, like, your body, which is kind of the biggest thing you have that's with you at all times, is kind of being given over to these other people and, you know, your life becomes so out of control so early. It was incredibly difficult. Yeah, I think that's the thing with dealing with an AVM is that it's, or any chronic illness where there is no end in sight, there's no cure. It's so hard because you
它就被交给了医生，被缝合、被切开，它感觉不像是我的。所以在我的大半生中，我真的对自己的身体没有自主权，
just feel like a duck that's just kind of trying to tread above water and you never know like I could have a good period for a month and then suddenly like you know hell breaks loose and I'm in hospital having nine bleeds a day oh my god so I'm you know I'm doing things like the Oscars or things like that but the anxiety I felt like leading up to the Oscars because it felt like something that was set in stone and my life is so not set in stone that anything like that it's like I never get excited for it because the nerves of this isn't going to have. happen or something's going to happen that means that this, you know, doesn't follow through is so big and has been in my life that's been the case, that it's very hard for me to look
这真的是一件很难的事情，因为我认为当你年轻的时候，你知道的，你正在试图找到自己，找到你是谁，并有一种自我意识和身份认同。所以当你的身体——它基本上是你随时带在身边最大的东西——被交给这些其他人时，你知道的，你的生活这么早就变得如此失控。这实在是太难了。是的，我想这就是应对AVM的问题所在，那就是它，或者任何看不到尽头、无法治愈的慢性病。太难了，因为你
forward to things and instead be so anxious that it's not even going to happen. Yeah. Yeah. This is the thing that I was so interested in talking to you about is the psychological side of a chronic illness. And the fact that a lot of people, as you said, would see, I don't know, a visual. difference and that would be it. Yeah. And I think it's so important that you talk about and that you are talking to us about, no, there's all this other side of it. Like this, the mental load of the anxiety
觉得自己就像一只在水面上拼命划水的鸭子，你永远不知道，比如我可能有一个月的平静期，然后突然间，你知道的，地狱之门大开，我一天要在医院出九次血，哦天哪，所以我，你知道的，我在做像出席奥斯卡或者类似的事情，但在奥斯卡之前感到的焦虑，因为它感觉像是一件板上钉钉的事，而我的生活又是如此不确定，任何这样的时候，我都觉得我从来不会为此感到兴奋，因为“这不会发生”或者“会有什么事情发生导致这个，你知道的，无法实现”的紧张感太大了，而且在我的生活中一直都是这样，这让我很难去期待什么事情，相反却焦虑得甚至觉得它根本不会发生。是的。是的。这就是我非常想和你聊的事情，即慢性病的心理层面。以及很多人，正如你所说，会看到，我不知道，一个视觉上的差异，然后就那样了。是的。而且我认为非常重要的是，你谈到了这一点，并且你正在和我们谈论，“不，还有所有这些其他方面。”比如这个，你所解释的焦虑所带来的精神负担。
that you're explaining. And what really struck me about that was you being like, yeah, all these great things are happening. Imagine not being able to even look forward to the good stuff because of how just stressful that might be. Yeah. I've been in and out of therapy my whole life. for different things. I'm in therapy at the moment, having EMDR for chronic PTSD. Yeah. So how are you finding it?
而真正让我印象深刻的是，你说，“是的，所有这些棒极了的事情正在发生。”想象一下，因为这会带来多么巨大的压力，你甚至无法去期待那些美好的事情。是的。我一生中都在进出心理诊所，
It's hard. Oh my gosh. It is. I went into EMDR because it kind of felt like the only option. CBT wasn't going to work for me because I knew. You can't rationalize. Yeah. I'm almost too over therapists.
为了不同的事情。我目前正在做心理治疗，通过EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）来治疗复杂的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。是的。所以你觉得效果怎么样？
Like I know everything. I know why things have happened. I know my mental place is a product of my physical health mostly. And so I know all of that. So that's not going to work for me. I needed to feel like I was doing something that was like progress and an actual tangible thing because so much of my life has been things that haven't been that. So talking about issues is great and you definitely need to do that.
很难。天哪。确实如此。我之所以选择EMDR，是因为它感觉像是唯一的选择。CBT（认知行为疗法）对我不适用，因为我知道。你无法理性化。是的。我对治疗师都有点免疫了。
But that's just ruminating. So EMDR for me, I've had 15 sessions of it. I've got five left. It's a lot. When we first started doing EMDR with my therapist, we actually made a, like almost a timeline of all of the traumatic things that have happened to me since I was six years old and it was like two pages long and it was the most crazy thing to and we kind of put the dates or that was a bit blurry and like named each experience and it was so insane to kind of see
就像我什么都知道。我知道为什么事情会发生。我知道我的心理状态主要是我身体健康的产物。所以我都知道这些。所以那对我不适用。我需要觉得我在做一些有进展、有实际tangible（触手可及）的事情，因为我生命中的大部分时间都是那些没有进展的事情。所以谈论问题很好，你也绝对需要这样做。
your trauma kind of laid out like that and so then we kind of went through okay which one is the worst out of all of the worst traumas and have been targeting that and it is the most kind of the biggest workout for your brain ever um i do think that it's helping but after i do EMDR i'm like gone for the whole day so tired so exhausted i remember the first time i had a EMDR i literally thought i'd been drugged i was like what has happened to me i can't function dizzy dizzy just knocked out like i just felt like i wasn't in my body because obviously you kind of also dissociate a little bit when you're doing that because you're back in the experience. So EMDR's great because I feel like it's directly kind of attacking certain things that
但这只是反刍。所以对我和EMDR来说，我已经做了15次了。我还剩5次。这很不简单。当我们刚开始和我的治疗师做EMDR时，我们实际上制作了一个——几乎是一条时间线，记录了我从6岁开始经历的所有创伤事件，它有两页纸那么长，这真的是最疯狂的事情，然后我们标上了日期，或者说有点模糊，并给每个经历起了名字，看到自己的创伤像那样被铺开，真的是太疯狂了。然后我们开始梳理，“好吧，在所有最糟糕的创伤中，哪一个是最糟糕的？”并针对那个进行干预，这绝对是对大脑最大的一次锻炼。
have happened to me. It's hard because I'm also dealing with the reality still in a way. But it means that because you're bringing up like the worst things that have ever happened to you that you would naturally push back in the back of your mind, you're then kind of, you have your EMDR and then the rest of your week you're left with that, kind of just being at the surface of your mind and having to deal with that. So that's, yeah, it's hard. But I'm kind of relieved that I feel like I'm doing something that has like a beginning
嗯，我确实认为这有帮助，但在做完EMDR之后，我整个人一整天都废了，太累了，精疲力竭。我记得第一次做EMDR时，我简直以为自己被下药了，我当时想，我这是怎么了？我无法正常运转，头晕目眩，直接被放倒——我只是觉得自己不属于自己的身体了，因为显然在做那个的时候你也会有点解离（dissociate），因为你又回到了那种经历中。所以EMDR很好，因为我觉得它直接在攻击某些发生在我身上的事情。这很难，因为从某种程度上说，我仍然在面对现实。但这意味着，因为你唤起了那些你经历过的最糟糕的事情——你本能地会把它们压抑在心底——然后你会经历EMDR，而在接下来的那一周里，你就得带着那些东西生活，它们就停留在你脑海的表面，你必须去面对它们。所以这，是的，这很难。但我有点欣慰，因为我觉得我正在做一件有头有尾的事情。
and an end in a way. Yeah. And I think also like you have been, not to put words in your mouth, but you have been in medical institutions for the majority of your life. You have probably an incredible medical like A, knowledge, B, dictionary of terms, C, psychological understanding. I'm sure you've met a million psychologists. a million caseworkers, a million social workers.
是的。而且我也觉得，不是想替你做决定，但你的大半生都是在医疗机构里度过的。你可能拥有惊人的医学知识库——A，知识，B，术语词典，C，心理学理解。我确信你见过一百万个心理学家、
I feel like for somebody like you, who is incredibly self-aware, it's something I see with like CVT all the time, where it's just like incredibly difficult to not just hear what somebody else to say. Be like, come on, I heard that. Exactly. Had that a million times. Cool. We've got the knowledge.
一百万个个案工作者、一百万个社工。我觉得对于像你这样自我意识极强的人来说，我在CBT（认知行为疗法）中经常看到这种情况，就是极其难得不去听别人在说些什么，而是会想：“得了吧，这话我听过。
I need to do something practical. I'm so glad that it's working. Yeah. And my therapist keeps catching me out because we'll be going through a memory and I'll say she'll always stop me and be like, what do you feel now? What do you see now? And I'll start, I can't just say the thing. I have to then analyze the thing and explain it.
完全没错。听过一百万遍了。酷。知识我们都有了。我需要做点实际的事情。”我很高兴它正在起作用。是的。我的治疗师一直在抓我的包袱，因为我们在梳理记忆时，她总是会停下来问：“你现在感觉到了什么？你现在看到了什么？”然后我就会开始——我不能只是说出那件事。我接着得分析那件事并解释它。
And she's like, stop analyzing it. Just stop analyzing, just say the thing and continue. And I think it comes from like that being, that's the thing is when you're so over kind of therapies and so self-aware. I mean, I'm so self-waring of my body. I've had to be tapped into it. That you do that in general too much. That then I feel like it's almost also me trying to.
然后她说：“别分析了。别再分析了，直接说那件事然后继续。”我想这源于——问题就在于此，当你对治疗感到厌倦且极具自我意识时（我的意思是，我对自己的身体有着极高的自我意识，我不得不保持这种敏锐），你在日常生活中也往往做得过头了。以至于我觉得这几乎也是我在试图
to, because I'm so used to no one understanding that I have to over explain, overcompensate, over justify. So I find that I'm doing a lot in therapy. And my therapist is always calling me out being like, just go with the feeling. You don't need to explain the feeling. Yeah. You don't need to make sense of it. Just go with it. So interesting that you said like you're so in touch with your body because probably like mostly your condition would like necessitate that. Like any pain might be incredibly threatening or important to like deal with. Yeah. That it's like even when you're trying to like heal through trauma,
去……因为我太习惯了没有人理解，所以我不得不过度解释、过度补偿、过度证明。所以我发现我在治疗中做了很多这样的事。我的治疗师总是指出来说：“顺着这种感觉走就行。你不需要解释这种感觉。是的。你不需要让它合乎逻辑。顺其自然吧。”真有趣，你说你对自己的身体如此敏锐，因为可能主要是你的病情需要你这样做。就像任何疼痛都可能具有极大的威胁性或对处理问题至关重要一样。是的。以至于即使当你试图通过创伤进行疗愈时，
you probably feel that in your body a lot more intensely than most people as well. Totally. And it's this weird thing where I'm constantly kind of in this fight or flight mode where, you know, I could have the tiniest kind of niggle of feeling and I'm like, oh my God, where are my tissues? I'm going to have a nosebleed. And that has been the case sometimes because my nosebleeds can just come on out of nowhere. So you're constantly kind of preparing for danger.
你可能比大多数人更强烈地在身体中感受到这一点。完全是这样。而且这是一种奇怪的状态，我经常处于这种战斗或逃跑模式中，你知道的，我只要有一点点细微的不适感，就会想：“天哪，我的纸巾在哪儿？我要流鼻血了。”有时确实如此，因为我的鼻血会毫无征兆地突然涌出。所以你一直在为危险做准备。
Your body's constantly in that kind of state, which means that I'm never able to kind of relax or return to a baseline. And so like with my therapist, we've been talking about a lot about window of tolerance. And, you know, obviously the window of tolerance when you have a lot of traumatic events or a destabilized kind of nervous system or dysregulated, that your window of tolerance is so much smaller. and you bounce up above it or down below it much quicker.
你的身体一直处于那种状态，这意味着我永远无法放松或回到基线状态。所以就像我的治疗师，我们一直在讨论容纳窗（window of tolerance）。而且，很明显，当你经历了很多创伤事件，或者神经系统不稳定、失调时，你的容纳窗要小得多，
So hyper or hypo arousal. And so for me, I think what's been helpful with therapy is I'm so self-aware, but I also treat that self-awareness as like I'm very hard on myself. And so what it's helped me with is being able to apply these theories to myself and make sense of them when a lot of my life has been not being able to kind of put something in a box, and make sense of it as just that because it's so much and it's so messy. But equally, you know, I'm so tapped into my body, but I'm also, I've been through a lot of like dissociation from my body and detachment where it's because it's not felt like mine,
你会更快地向上或向下摆动。也就是过度觉醒或觉醒不足。所以对我来说，我觉得治疗有帮助的地方在于，我虽然很有自我意识，但我也会把这种自我意识当作对自己非常苛刻的工具。它对我的帮助在于，能够把这些理论应用到自己身上，并在我一生中的很多时候无法将某些东西装进盒子里、无法将其简单合理化时，去理解它们——因为经历实在太多太杂乱了。但同样地，你知道的，我对自己的身体极度敏锐，但我也经历过很多与身体的解离和疏离，因为（身体）感觉不像是我的，
it doesn't feel like it's mine. I remember I had a massive surgery a few years ago. It was a 12-hour surgery and I was recovering for four and a half months. And that was one of the, I mean, the rock bottom of my life, that whole recovery period. And I remember looking at my hands and being like, these hands don't feel attached to my body. Like I felt so outside of my body because so much had happened that it was kind of like, yeah, you need to shut down to just survive through this. But yeah, I think, you know, therapy is one of those things where it's almost like the most important relationship outside of the one you have with yourself to have. A good therapist or a bad therapist or psychologist can make or break your experience.
它就真的感觉不像是我的。我记得几年前我做过一次大型手术。那是一场12小时的手术，我恢复了四个半月。那是我人生中——我的意思是，我人生的谷底，整个康复期。我记得看着自己的双手，心想：这些手感觉不像是长在我身上的。我感觉自己如此抽离出自己的身体，因为发生了太多事情，以至于感觉就像是：是的，你需要关闭系统才能熬过这一切。但话又说回来，你知道的，治疗就是这样一种关系，它几乎是你除了与自己的关系之外最重要的关系。一个好的治疗师或糟糕的治疗师、心理学家可以成就或毁掉你的体验。
Yes. Because I've had some rubbish ones where I go into it. instantly and know in my gut this isn't going to work. How do you know that? It's just a feeling I get. It's almost like, I guess, like speed dating, like or dating. It's that feeling of like, yeah, this isn't going to work or this, I feel like this could work.
是的。因为我遇到过一些糟糕的治疗师，我一进去
Obviously, you know, you can't, you need time to see, but I do feel like for me, the person matters as much as the therapy. So I feel like, and also in my life, a lot of doctors for medical stuff haven't. seen me as a whole person. They've seen me as a problem that needs fixing. I was going to say, I feel like you would have a good nose for it because you probably dealt with a lot of people in this setting. You can tell who has genuine empathy. Yeah. Is that, do you think your empathy radar is quite too high? Too high. Oh my God. In the sense of I'm such a deep feeler and I'm so overly aware of like there could be a change in energy in the room and I'm like, someone's angry
就立刻在直觉上知道这行不通。你是怎么知道的？这只是一种感觉。这几乎就像——我猜——就像快速约会，或者约会。那种感觉就是：“是的，这行不通”或者“这，我觉得这可能会行得通”。很显然，你知道的，你不能——你需要时间去观察，但我确实觉得对我来说，这个人本身和疗法同样重要。所以我觉得，在我的生活中，很多看医疗问题的医生也没有把我当作一个完整的人来看待。他们把我当作一个需要修复的问题。我正想说，我觉得你对这种事会有敏锐的嗅觉，因为你可能在这个环境中和很多人打过交道。你能看出谁拥有真正的同理心。是的。是不是——你觉得你的同理心雷达是不是有点太高了？太高了。天哪。那种感觉就是我是一个感情极度深沉的人，我对房间里能量的变化过于敏感，我会觉得：有人在生我的气。有人不高兴，你知道的。所以我对此极其敏感。而且我认为我完全，我完全理解，尤其是在医疗视角下，医生必须将自己从工作中抽离出来。我的意思是，我永远无法日复一日地做他们所做的事情，你知道的，传达沉重的消息，做这些疯狂的手术，然后回家把这一切都背负在自己身上。你知道的，你不能那样做。你必须学会抽离。对待治疗和治疗师以及其他事情也是如此。但同样地，很多医生在我很小的时候就一直这样看着我、对我说：
with me. Someone's upset, you know. So I'm so aware of that. And I think I completely, I completely understand, especially in a medical lens, that doctors have to detach themselves from their work. I mean, I could never do what they do day and day out, you know, delivering hard news, doing these insane surgeries and then go home and carry that all with me. You know, you can't do that. You have to learn to detach. Same with therapy and therapists and whatever else. But equally, a lot of doctors have kind of seen me and told me through my life from a very early age,
跟我在一起。有人很不高兴，你知道的。所以我对此非常敏感。而且我想我完全、我完全理解，特别是在医学的角度上，医生必须将自己与工作隔离开来。我的意思是，我永远无法做到他们日复一日所做的事情，你知道，传达沉重的消息，做那些疯狂的手术，然后回家把这一切都带在身上。你知道，你不能那样做。你必须学会抽离。治疗师和心理治疗师以及其他什么职业也是如此。但同样地，很多医生在我很小的时候就一路见证了我，并告诉我，
you're complicated. This is complex. You're a problem. You're an 11 out of 10. And so you apply that to you as a person, especially when you're so young. Or this can't be fixed. So it's like you're constantly kind of sat in this hospital waiting room and watching everyone else around you leave the room,
“你很复杂。这很棘手。你是个难题。你是个11分（满分10分）的棘手案例。”所以你会把这些标签套用在自己身上，尤其是当你还很小的时候。或者“这无法修复”。所以这就好像你不断地坐在医院候诊室里，看着身边的每个人都离开房间，
but you're still stuck in it because your problem is never solved. And a lot of doctors have kind of seen me as, yeah, a problem and not as a whole human. They think, okay, we can do this drastic surgery that might help you, but they're not thinking how is that going to impact my life? Yeah. How is that going to impact me as a human? How is that going to impact me as a 13 year old, 15 year old, 21 year old who wants to also live as much of a normal life as she possibly can? And so I think that's been a really hard, like, paradox is that, of course, I need, you know, to have the health support and the medical support. But a lot of doctors have never seen me as a whole person. So it's like as soon as I leave that hospital, I know that they're not considering what I'm going through outside of the hospital. hospital. Like it's like you get discharged from hospital and it's like okay off you go. Yeah. But no, then you're, I'm dealing with four and a half months of recovery in my room, not leaving it. And do you think sometimes they see it was like an intellectual problem maybe for
而你却依然被困在里面，因为你的问题永远没有解决。很多医生都把我视为——是的，是一个问题，而不是一个完整的人。他们认为，好吧，我们可以做这个可能对你有帮助的激进手术，但他们没有考虑这会如何影响我的生活？是的。这会如何影响我作为一个人？这会如何影响我作为一个13岁、15岁、21岁、也想尽可能过上正常生活的女孩？所以我认为这是一个非常艰难的、类似悖论的事情，那就是，当然，我需要健康支持和医疗支持。但很多医生从未把我视为一个完整的人。所以就好像我一离开那家医院，我就知道他们根本没有考虑我在医院之外经历了什么。就好像你从医院出院了，然后就是：好吧，走吧。但不对，接着我得在自己的房间里应付四个半月的康复期，大门不出二门不迈。你觉得有时他们把它看作是一个智力上的问题吗？
them? Yeah. Yeah. Where they're like, you're a challenge. This is interesting to me. Or I've had a lot of, which is no problem with that, but a lot of like, um, junior doctors who've come in and they've been like, can they, you know, be a part of this appointment so they can see your case and stuff like. that like I remember once when I was younger going into a doctor's appointment and having about I think I must have been nine and having about 14 doctors surrounding me like that so and you were nine yeah you would have been really scary especially know their names didn't know their names probably and then also when most people and you included would see a doctor you'd be like something's really wrong having that many doctors around you would probably have thought the worst yeah
是的。是的。他们会觉得：“你是一个挑战。这很有趣。”或者我经历过很多——这倒不是什么问题，但有很多初级医生走进来，他们会说：“她能不能（你知道的）参与这次预约，这样他们就能看你的病例了之类的”——我记得有一次我小的时候去医院看病，大概——我当时一定九岁吧——周围围了大约14个医生，就像那样。你当时九岁？那一定非常可怕，尤其是你可能甚至不知道他们的名字，可能连他们的名字都不知道，而且当大多数人和包括你在内的所有人看到一个医生时，你会觉得：“出大事了。”周围有那么多医生，你当时可能已经做最坏的打算了。是的。
god that's really hard yeah yeah I can imagine You and a pal in Montreal and Oceaga, with four nights at Residents in downtown Montreal, flights from Porter Airlines, two weekend gold tickets, and $1,000 cash. Please, Lord, Zara Larson, Dima Gray, Sombor, 21 pilots, and more. Download IHeart Radio, listen to IHeart new music for 10 minutes, and enter to win. Oceaga, 2026. Every day you listen is another chance to win. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live.
天哪，那真的很难。是的。是的，我可以想象。你和一位好友将前往蒙特利尔和奥谢加音乐节（Osheaga），享受在蒙特利尔市中心Residence酒店的四晚住宿、波特航空公司的机票、两张周末黄金门票以及1000加元现金。求求老天，扎拉·拉尔森（Zara Larsson）、迪玛·格雷（Dima Gray）、索姆博（Sombor）、二十一名飞行员（21 Pilots）等等。下载iHeartRadio，收听iHeart新音乐10分钟，即可参与赢取。奥谢加音乐节，2026年。你收听的每一天都是又一次获胜的机会。那一刻，感觉就像过了一个世纪。我以为自己活不成了。
I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir.
我吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以毫不夸张地说，这是你职业生涯中最大的案子吗？是的，长官。
Rape and murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place. by Creveh and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum.
针对儿童的强奸和谋杀。简直不能再恶劣了。我想是的。人们，醒醒吧。我是那个目睹了克里瓦奇和德皮波谋杀案发生的人。安东尼·德皮波毫无悔意，在被判处最高刑罚时显得无动于衷。
I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people.
我说我没有罪。我要把它带进坟墓。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。并在苹果播客上订阅Love for Good Plus，无广告收听《魔鬼采石场》并享受独家内容。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《霍达·科特比的快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）的主持人。在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话。
Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Everyone is a total of excitement
就像女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时所说的那样。我曾经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，而那更为艰难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。每个人都充满兴奋，
because their new star is Javier Tchirito Hernandez Everyone sees me as a football player But before anything else, I'm human Every single day I'm still learning How to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born And I still have so many questions Where do we come from? What happens after death?
因为他们的全新球星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我当成一名足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与自我出生以来的种种问题、错误、人际关系和情感共处。而且我依然有这么多的问题：我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？
How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From everyday and ordinary, the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast.
你如何应对被取消（cancel）？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱情？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常与平凡，到深刻与非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。
Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shut. All in this life has a order perfect and all is just. Wait me, I'm going to pressure me, but me will go to be able to be done. We are here to connect.
这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像是与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深度交谈，脆弱感流露无遗。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标与教训被直言不讳。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等我，我要给自己施加压力，但我也一定能够做到。我们来到这里是为了连接。
The Chicharito. And Javier and Chicharito Hernandez, and together with Iha Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is.
我是小豌豆。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，与iHeartRadio一起，我们将把平凡变得非凡。保持关注。这是个特色。在iHeartRadio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。这里有一些本不该如此复杂的事情。
Getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is. Getting a new one put up in its place. As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of remembering the Civil War. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Lee Boulevard. Get to the grocery store. I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job.
移除种族主义雕像。接下来这件事应该比实际情况容易得多。在原址上竖起一块新的雕像。只要美国还存在种族政治，关于内战的记忆政治就会一直存在。为了去学校，我不得不走罗伯特·李大道。去杂货店。我不得不走杰斐逊·达拉斯大道。如果你是一位历史学家，却漏掉了历史的一半，那你就是在失职。
I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence. We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching.
我是阿基拉·休斯，《反叛精神》第二季将深入探讨这两方面的内容。冲突、政治、获胜的人，以及我为肯塔基州议会大厦增添一件真正配得上这面墙壁的东西而展开的个人运动。我们不仅仅是我们的躯体。我们包含着本质。我们包含着精神。你如何体现这一点？他们只是在火上浇油，而且火势真的蔓延开了。
You'll see what I mean. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you want to talk about your YouTube channel? Yeah, let's do it. Yeah. Do you want to talk about what it's been like spending so much of your life on social media? Yeah, like crazy. How is your relationship to it changed?
你们会明白我的意思的。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。你想聊聊你的YouTube频道吗？好的，我们开始吧。好的。你想聊聊把那么多生命时光花在社交媒体上是什么感觉吗？是的，简直太疯狂了。你和它的关系发生了怎样的变化？
Like before we started, the listeners need to know, we were just like chatty Kathy's before. Oh my God, yeah. It was so good. Yeah. And you were talking about how, you know, you started TikTok and you got like a million followers in like a month. But that individual, that younger you who like started it as an escape to now, like, yeah, how has the relationship changed?
就像我们开始之前，听众需要知道的，我们之前就像“喋喋不休的凯西”一样。哦天哪，是的。太棒了。是的。你在谈论，你知道的，你是怎么开始做TikTok的，然后在大概一个月内就获得了大约一百万粉丝。但是那个作为逃避现实而开始这一切的个体，那个年轻时的你，到现在，是的，这种关系发生了怎样的变化？
Such good question. I mean, it's changed a lot. When I first started YouTube and put myself on social media, there was no part of my brain that was like, this is going to be a job. I need to perform or be a certain way. There was no part of my brain because it's also that innocent still that you you have as a child that this is play. I'm going to do this for fun. Like, you know, this is for me, which all of us as adults, we lose that. And that's a lot of what I talk about and just think
真是个好问题。我的意思是，它改变了很多。当我刚开始做YouTube并把自己展露在社交媒体上时，我的脑子里根本没有一丝“这将是一份工作”的想法。我需要表现或者表现得像某种特定的人。我的脑子里完全没有这种想法，因为那种纯真依然存在，就像你小时候所拥有的那样，这只是玩耍。我要为了好玩而做这件事。就像，你知道的，这是为了我自己，而我们成年人所有这些都失去了。这就是我生活中经常谈论和思考的很多事情，就是我如何需要以某种方式重新找回那种感觉。
about in life is how I need to tap back into that somehow. Yeah, with the new podcast. Yeah, exactly. Like I talk a lot about how life becomes and think a lot about how life becomes so serious that we actually lose playtime. And if anything, adults need that more than even kids because there's so much more that takes away playtime. We need to do a whole episode on this. Oh my God, I would love that. It's a deep personal philosophy of mine. I'm glad that you were great.
是的，通过新的播客。是的，完全正确。就像我经常谈论并且经常思考生活是如何变得如此严肃，以至于我们实际上失去了玩耍的时间。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是成年人比孩子们更需要这个，因为有太多其他事情剥夺了玩耍的时间。我们应该专门做一整期节目来聊这个。哦天哪，我太乐意了。这是我深信不服的个人哲学。我很高兴你很棒。
I would love that. I knew that as soon as we met, we would just hit it off. I love playtime. I honestly do so many episodes where like we talk about whimsy and fun. Same. Bingo. But I feel like when we're kids, you were talking about like you started YouTube as like this thing is an escape and also because it was fun.
我太乐意了。我知道我们一见面就会一拍即合。我真的超级喜欢玩耍。老实说，我做了很多期节目，都在谈论异想天开和开心。我也是。完全赞同。但我觉得当我们还是孩子的时候，你刚才说你开始做YouTube就像是一种逃避，也是因为这很有趣。
Yeah. And now it's your job. Yes. Do you love it less? I do. If I'm going to be honest, I miss, I mean, social media, and I'm sure you can agree, has changed so much as a landscape. It's become, in an amazing way, it's become very legitimate now and it's become something that you can do, you know, financially. Like, I remember when it was like the Zoellas and stuff, how they kind of still weren't really taken that seriously. Or like, it was like, why is she so successful? I don't understand. Whereas now it's, you know, it's one of the biggest markets in the world, social media. But I miss the, I think this also just happens with growing up you become more self-aware of yourself and more aware of how people perceive you and how you perceive you and our external opinions and voices and that is really difficult and also when you become your work it's this really hard thing where where does Nikki Lilly start
是的。而现在它成了你的工作。是的。你没那么爱它了吗？确实没有。如果要说实话的话，我很怀念，我的意思是，社交媒体——我相信你也会同意——作为一片天地，已经发生了巨大的变化。它以一种了不起的方式变得非常正规，并成为了一件你可以通过它获得经济回报的事情，你知道的。就像，我记得当年的Zoellas之类的人，他们当时并没有真正被太严肃地对待。或者说，就像，为什么她会这么成功？我不理解。而现在，你知道的，社交媒体是世界上最大的市场之一。但我怀念那种感觉，我想这也伴随着成长而发生，你会对自我有更多的自觉，更加意识到别人是如何看待你的，你是如何看待你自己的，以及我们外界的观点和声音，这真的很困难。而且，当你变成了你的工作，就会出现一个非常棘手的问题：尼基·莉莉从哪里开始，
and where does Nikki Lili and Nikki Lili obviously is still me my name is Nikki my middle name is Lily but in a way I've had to create a little bit of distance from both in order to hang her up at the end of the day and still be me. Nikki is me but it's also like to others an inspiring, more inspiring version of me. It's a more aspirational version of me, more positive as all of us are on social media. It's just a heightened version.
尼基·莉莉又在哪里结束？当然，尼基·莉莉依然是我，我叫尼基，我的中间名是莉莉。但在某种程度上，我不得不与这两者保持一点距离，以便在一天结束时把“尼基·莉莉”这个身份挂起来，依然做回真正的我。尼基是我，但对其他人来说，她也是一个激励人心的、更具启发性的版本的我。她是一个更具抱负版本的我，更积极向上，就像我们在社交媒体上所有人一样。这只是一个被夸大的版本。
And it's been incredible because honestly I don't think there's many jobs if any I could have had with my circumstances except social media. So in that way it's been, you know, such a gift and I'm so, so lucky because having such unpredictable health, you know, tomorrow I could be in hospital, I just don't know. It would be incredibly hard for me to maintain a job for like a company, a normal nine to five. And so in that way, I'm so grateful that I've been able to, alongside my condition, do and have a job because that's what a lot of people with disabilities struggle with is that a lot of people have
这简直太不可思议了，因为老实说，除了社交媒体之外，以我的情况来看，我几乎不可能找到其他什么工作，如果有的话。所以从这个意义上说，你知道的，这真是一份巨大的礼物，我感到非常非常幸运，因为我的健康状况如此难以预测，你知道的，明天我可能就会进医院，我根本无从知晓。要我维持一份为某家公司工作、正常的朝九晚五的工作，会难如登天。因此，从这个意义上说，我非常感激自己能够在伴随着病情的同时，还能做一份工作并拥有一份工作，因为这正是许多残疾人所苦恼的事情，不幸的是，许多人不得不为此依赖他人。
to rely on others for that, unfortunately. And so I think how social media has changed for me is that I still absolutely love it. I think the hard part for me now is because I'm such an overthinker, because I'm such a perfectionist as we've been talking about. And I lack so much control in myself, I try and find that even more from my job because also my job is me. So it links back to that. I'm showing you feel the same.
因此，我认为社交媒体对我来说改变的地方在于，我仍然绝对热爱它。现在对我来说困难的部分在于，因为我想得太多，因为正如我们一直在讨论的那样，我是一个完美主义者。并且我对自己的掌控力如此匮乏，以至于我试图从我的工作中寻找更多这样的控制，因为我的工作同时也是我自己。所以这又回到了这一点。我确信你也有同感。
And so the hard part is how do I make videos? that still fulfill that younger part of me that is just for fun, but also how do I make videos that perform well for my job? And that is the paradox that I deal with every single day. Yeah. Yeah, I'm sure you feel the same. Yeah, I do. And it's just such a weird thing where you're like,
所以困难的部分在于，我该如何制作既能满足我内心那个只为了好玩而存在的年轻自我，同时又能为我的工作带来良好表现的视频？这就是我每天都要面对的悖论。是的。是的，我相信你也有同感。是的，我也有。这真是一件很奇怪的事情，你会觉得：
I want to keep parts of me private. But I also know that like we've gotten to the stage of social media where the only thing left that people care about is just like extreme vulnerability. Exactly. Because they're like, I've seen it all. all. I've seen it all. And we're like getting to like, I feel like like digging down and what everybody wants like the most vulnerable nugget of truth about you for them to consume. And sometimes I'm like, I don't really want to do that. That's why I like don't have TikTok because I was just like I just can't give over every single part of my life to an audience. Yeah. Especially since I've spent my whole 20s talking about what it's like basically documenting. You've chronicled your 20s. It's crazy. I know like two episodes a week. I talk about myself for two hours. It's getting a little bit boring at this point. But you know like. No, I get it. Do you know what I mean?
我想在一定程度上保持隐私。但我也知道，我们已经达到了社交媒体的这样一个阶段，人们唯一还关心的就是极端的脆弱性。完全正确。因为他们会想，我都见识过了。我都见识过了。我们正在接近，我觉得就像是在挖掘每个人都想消费的、关于你最脆弱的真相核心。有时候我在想，我其实不想那么做。这就是为什么我不用TikTok，因为我只是觉得自己无法把生活的每一个部分都交给受众。是的。尤其是自从我整个二十多岁都在谈论记录生活是什么感觉以来。你一直在记录你的二十多岁。这太疯狂了。我知道，就像每周两期节目。我连续两个小时都在谈论我自己。现在这变得有点无聊了。但你知道的。
There's only so much like you can scrape the barrel. Have you ever considered quitting social media? I know you said it's this amazing job for you. But have you think a lot of us when we hit that burnout phase, and I've kind of been in it recently a lot, if I'm going to be honest. I don't think I've ever been more burnt out in my life. Really? Okay. Yeah, I don't know what it is.
不，我懂。你知道我的意思吗？你在竭尽所能地压榨自己。你有没有考虑过放弃社交媒体？我知道你说过这是一份很棒的工作。但当你经历精疲力竭的阶段时，我想我们很多人都会这样——老实说，我最近挺常处于这种状态的。我觉得我一生中从未像现在这样筋疲力尽过。真的吗？好吧。是的，我不知道为什么。
I think that I've, what's been incredible is me being able to do things like the Oscars or like in two weeks I'm going to Cannes Film Festival or, you know, these massive moments speaking at the United Nations. I've done so many incredible things that I almost then go back to my baseline of life and I'm like, okay, what do I post now? What do I talk about now? I feel very lost in between those moments.
我认为我，令人难以置信的是我能够做一些事情，比如去奥斯卡颁奖典礼，或者两周后我要去戛纳电影节，或者，你知道的，这些极其重要的时刻，在联合国发表演讲。我做过那么多不可思议的事情，以至于我几乎要回到生活的基准线，然后心想：好吧，我现在该发什么？现在该聊什么？在那些高光时刻之间，我感到非常迷失。
Even though I know what I need to do, I know what I need to talk about, but it's almost like there's this barrier mentally that I'm also like, I have so many ideas, I have so many thoughts, where do I start? And then that's when I start spiraling because I don't have a very logical brain. My brain goes straight to emotion.
尽管我知道自己需要做什么，我知道自己需要谈论什么，但精神上似乎有一种障碍，让我同时产生这样的想法：我有那么多的主意，我有那么多的想法，我该从哪里开始呢？然后，我就会开始陷入恶性循环，因为我的大脑不具备很强的逻辑性。我的大脑直接诉诸情绪。
So then it's kind of like me being like, maybe I'm just not cut out for this job. And then I watch videos on TikTok and it's like I can't enjoy the videos because I'm just comparing myself to maybe their engagement or maybe their idea. And so would I stop social media?
所以这有点像我在对自己说：也许我根本不适合这份工作。然后我在TikTok上刷视频，却无法享受这些视频的乐趣，因为我只会拿自己跟别人的参与度或者别人的创意作比较。所以我会停用社交媒体吗？
I mean, at this point, not in the near future. I still have so much that I want to do. And for me, it's such a special place. I found a community on it. It's given me a sense of purpose. It's given me a sense of control and reclamation of my life. But equally, it isn't a job that has much stability. And so that is the hard part is when in my life I want control and I search for it so deeply.
我的意思是，就目前而言，近期内不会。我还有那么多想做的事。对M我来说，这是一个非常特别的地方。我在上面找到了一个社群。它给了我一种目标感。它给了我一种对生活的控制感和夺回主动权的感觉。但同样地，它并不是一份拥有高度稳定性的工作。所以困难的部分在于，当我的生活中渴望控制并且如此深切地寻找它时，
And then when you have a job that does not have the stability, I don't go into, in an amazing way, I don't have to go into an office five days a week or three days a week. But equally, I don't have to go into an office five days or three days a week. So then what do I do with myself? and I thrive off of routine and structure and stability because my life and my body is the complete opposite of that. So then when you're kind of chucked into this job that is so last minute, that is so unpredictable, that is so reliant on other people, you know, your followers or brands or whatever else it may be, but equally so reliant on you because you are the product, you are the thing. And the cog doesn't move unless you're the one moving it with this job. it is so hard to not compare.
而你又拥有一份缺乏稳定性的工作——从一个美妙的层面来说，我不需要一周有五天或三天去办公室。但同样地，我也不需要一周有五天或三天去办公室。那我该拿自己怎么办呢？我靠例行公事、结构和稳定性蓬勃发展，因为我的生活和身体完全是反其道而行之的。所以当你被扔进这样一份如此临时起意、如此难以预测、如此依赖他人的工作时，你知道的，依赖你的粉丝、品牌或其他任何东西，但同时又极其依赖你，因为你就是产品，你就是那个核心。在这个工作中，如果不是你在推动齿轮，齿轮就不会转动。不去做比较真的太难了。
And I think maybe it's like this delayed burnout where I've been doing this for so long. Like I'm only 21, but if you can, like a lot of people started social media in COVID, which was kind of the natural trajectory and now they're doing social media full time. I've been doing it for like over a decade.
我想这也许是一种长期的职业倦怠，因为我做这个已经很久了。就像我才21岁，但如果你能，很多人在疫情期间开始接触社交媒体，这可以说是很自然的轨迹，现在他们全职做社交媒体。而我已经做了十多年了。
And so because of that, I feel like I've had this delayed kind of burnout. I've always gone through phases where I'm like, I don't know what I'm doing. I'm really lost. I'm really uninspired. This, that and the other. like we all do with jobs.
正因为如此，我觉得我经历了这种延迟爆发的职业倦怠。我总是经历一些阶段，觉得自己不知道自己在做什么。我真的很迷茫。我真的毫无灵感。诸如此类的事情。就像我们对工作的所有态度一样。
You know, we always question what we're doing even if we love our job. We always think, like, is the grass greener over here? You know, what should I be doing differently? And it's always great to want to grow. But I feel like I really struggle to take in where I'm at and be happy with it. So I feel like at the moment, I'm having a little bit of like a, what am I doing with my life? What do I post? Where do I go?
你知道的，即使我们热爱自己的工作，也总是会质疑我们在做什么。我们总是在想，草是不是更绿一些？你知道的，我应该做些什么不同的事情？想要成长总是好的。但我觉得我真的很难去接受自己当下所处的位置并为此感到快乐。所以我觉得眼下，我有点像是在经历“我到底在对生活做什么？我该发什么？我该去哪里？”
What's important? What do people want from me? And it's almost then, like, paralyzing because I'm then like, I don't know where to go or what to do. And so I will always love social media And even if, you know, a few years down the line I decide that I want to be less involved In the social media aspect I would always, I think, want to do something camera facing
什么才是最重要的？人们想从我这得到什么？这几乎让人产生一种瘫痪感，因为我当时会想：我不知道该去哪儿或该做什么。所以我永远都会热爱社交媒体。而且即使，你知道的，几年后我决定减少参与社交媒体的程度，我想我还是会想要做一些面对镜头的事情。
In some way. I feel like, you know, I've done so much work around advocacy To suddenly kind of, even though that would be completely fine To suddenly disappear, I think would be such a shame For the facial difference community And the, you know, disability community But there is a lot of times where I'm kind of like Is this right?
以某种方式。我觉得，你知道的，我已经围绕倡导工作做了那么多，如果突然之间——尽管这完全可以理解——如果突然消失，我觉得对于面部差异社群以及，你知道的，残疾人社群来说会是一个巨大的遗憾。但有很多时候，我还是会忍不住想：这对我来说真的对吗？
for me, am I doing this right? I don't know what I'm doing. So I'm a couple of weeks ago, I actually forced myself to leave London and I went to the countryside for like a couple of days of one of my friends. I saw that. Looked so cute. We literally were in like a shepherd's hut cabin in the middle of nowhere. I was like, where is that? No, honestly, we went to the new forest and it's kind of like a couple of hours outside of London. Absolutely loved it. We went into this small town and there were just donkeys on the pavement. Like they were pedestrians. It was amazing. So cute. So I need. I need. needed that because I think we can get so, it can feel like a rat race sometimes in this job.
我这样做对吗？我不知道自己在做什么。所以几周前，我其实强迫自己离开了伦敦，我去了乡村，和我的一个朋友待了几天。我看到了。看起来太可爱了。我们真的住在荒郊野岭的一个牧羊人小屋里。当时我在想：那是在哪里？不，说真的，我们去了新森林，大概在伦敦郊外几个小时车程的地方。我太喜欢那里了。我们走进这个小镇，人行道上竟然有驴子。就像它们是行路人一样。太棒了。太可爱了。所以我需要。我需要。我确实需要这个，因为我觉得在这个工作中，有时候感觉就像是一场激烈的盲目竞争。
And especially when I've been through a lot, it becomes a rat race and then some with all of the other stuff I've got on top. So I absolutely love what I do and I'm so grateful for what it's given me. You know, the fact that I went to the Oscars this year is insane. Like, could have never, ever, ever pictured myself in that room. But equally, I do all of these amazing things and then I kind of go back to reality and I'm like I don't know what to do with myself now because you're so kind of consumed when you're in the moment of that thing and then you go back to baseline I come back to London I go back home go back to my normal and I'm so happy showing my normal my normal has always actually been what's resonated most with people was my reality
尤其是当我经历了很多事情之后，这变成了一场无休止的残酷竞争，再加上我身上堆积的其他所有事情。所以我绝对热爱我所做的事，我也非常感激它带给我的这一切。你知道的，今年我去了奥斯卡颁奖典礼，这太疯狂了。就像，我做梦也从未、从未、从未想象过自己会出现在那个房间里。但同样地，我做了所有这些不可思议的事情，然后我回到了现实，心想：我现在不知道该拿自己怎么办了，因为当你身处其中时，你是如此全情投入，然后你回到了基准线，我回到了伦敦，我回到了家，回到了我的正常生活。我也很高兴展示我的正常生活，我的正常生活实际上一直最能引起人们的共鸣，那就是我生活的现实，
of my life but then I'm like where do I what is the balance you know it sounds very like golden handcuffs yeah where it's like this is a great job dream job Yeah. I'm like supporting myself. I'm going to these amazing things, but also like, God, sometimes I would like a break. And the thing with social media is like there is no break. Yeah. Because that's the job, right? That that is the job. Can we talk about your comment section for a second? Yeah. Oh, my comment section. There was a video that you made last year that it was like a trend of people in your comments of cropping, cropping your face and only showing one side of your. your face, yeah, and then essentially like flipping it and showing your face without... Using AI to literally ask, like, prompt it to do that. Yeah, to like remove, to remove half of your face, to remove your visual differences. I'm still getting it today as well. Really?
但随后我又会想：我在哪里？平衡点到底是什么？你知道的，这听起来很像“金色手铐”，对吧？就像这是一份很棒的工作，梦想中的工作。是的。我能自食其力。我去参加这些令人惊叹的活动，但与此同时，天哪，有时我真的很想休息一下。而社交媒体的问题在于，根本没有假期。是的。因为这就是工作，对吧？这就是工作。我们能聊聊你的评论区吗？可以。哦，我评论区。你去年做过一个视频，里面有一种趋势，就是你评论区的人会裁剪，裁剪你的脸，只展示你脸的一半，
God, people are awful. I know. Just how does it feel on people do that? It felt so dehumanizing. It was so weird because also it was on a video that was just a, trend. It was a photo of me when I was younger and then you swiped it. It was a photo of me now. And I think I got tens of thousands of comments all of a sudden of people, yeah, cropping the photo of me now to just show the left side of my face that doesn't have my condition
是的，然后基本上就像是把它翻转过来，在没有……的情况下展示你的脸。利用人工智能来直接要求、提示它这么做。是的，比如移除，移除你半边脸，移除你的视觉差异。直到今天我还在收到这样的评论。真的吗？
or commenting it and then saying wasted potential or the potential she could have had or Nikki, I've fixed it or commenting the photo of me where they'd got the like AR. I also like using AI for such a stupid thing to mirror my face so that it completely takes away that side of my face with my condition and then commenting it and saying, you look so pretty. Oh God. That's really sad. So sad. That makes me kind of emotional. That makes me really angry. Yeah. And it's like I've spent, it makes me emotional. I've actually felt emotional about it for a really long time. It's awful behavior. Yeah. I've spent my whole life. trying to accept myself, like, and hating myself, to be honest,
天哪，人们太可怕了。我知道。当人们这么做时，你是什么感觉？这感觉太非人性化了。这太诡异了，因为这也是在一个视频里发生的，那只是一个潮流。那是我小时候的一张照片，然后你一滑，是我现在的照片。突然之间，我收到了几万条评论，人们，是的，把我的照片裁切得只剩下左半边脸，也就是没有我那种病症的左半边脸。
like my appearance, my life, my body, hating it all. No one has been, out of all of all of the hate comments, no one has said to me something that I've not said to myself from a young age. I felt so out of control and I felt so angry with myself and my body that it was almost going against me. And yet I was still having to live with it. My body and my appearance felt like my enemy. And I just couldn't comprehend it.
或者在评论里说：真是浪费潜力，她本该拥有怎样的潜力，或者“尼基，我把它修复了”；或者评论那张经过他们用人工智能进行极其愚蠢的处理、将我的脸镜像对称的照片，完全抹去了我带有病症的那半边脸，然后评论道：“你看起来太漂亮了。”天哪。这真的令人难过。太难过了。这让我有点情绪激动。这让我真的很生气。是的。这就好像我花了——这让我情绪激动。我其实为此感到情绪波动很长时间了。这种行为太恶劣了。是的。我花了一生时间。
So the only thing I would do is self-hate. you know, all of that kind of stuff because it felt like controlled, like how, you know, what we all do. And so I've spent my whole life trying to accept the body and the face that I now have and my new reality and the fact that I don't look like an average person and see that as something that is not a negative thing. And I've internalised a lot of stuff growing up, you know, not looking the same as anyone in a room, constantly feeling like the black sheep or kind of othered and not being able to put
试图去接纳自己，比如，说实话，曾经痛恨自己，
in a box and that making people. uncomfortable, being set out on the street from a very early age and therefore not wanting to leave the house because of that, being scared of kids my own age that you normally would go outside and play with because they would be the ones pointing and whispering. And so they basically undid all of that self-work that I've done and the trauma that I've kind of internalised growing up undid all of that work I'd done to get through that and heal from that just through their comments. And even though obviously I'm so aware, and always tell myself, like, I see hate comments and I was like, poor you. Like, you must have such a sad life to do that.
讨厌自己的外表、生活、身体，恨之入骨。在所有的恶评中，没有一个人对我说过的话是我在很小的时候没有对自己说过的。我感到如此失控，我对自我和身体感到如此愤怒，觉得它好像在跟我作对。然而我却不得不与之共存。我的身体和外表感觉就像我的敌人。我简直无法理解这一切。
Like, that's what I was spending your time on. But this felt so personal. It felt completely different because you are going to the effort of screenshoting my face and cropping it and then commenting it and then, you know, captioning the comment or asking AI. You are going through steps to do this. Multiple points where you could say maybe this is a really awful idea. Exactly. you could question your conscience here. Even if you think that, even if you think, oh gosh, you would look so beautiful if both sides
所以我唯一能做的就是自我厌恶，你知道的，诸如此类的事情，因为这感觉像是可控的，就像，你知道的，我们所有人都会做的那样。所以我花了一生时间，试图去接受我现在的身体和脸庞，接受我的新现实，接受我长得不像普通人这一事实，并把这看作一件并非负面的事情。我在成长过程中内化了很多东西，你知道的，长得和房间里的任何人都不同，常常觉得自己像个异类或被边缘化，无法被放进一个盒子里，而这让人们感到不舒服，很小的时候就被指指点点，因此因为这个原因而不想离开家，害怕同龄的孩子——你本该出去和他们一起玩耍，因为他们正是那些指指点点、窃窃私语的人。因此，他们仅仅通过他们的评论，就毁了我所做过所有关于自我接纳的努力，毁了我成长过程中内化下来的创伤——他们摧毁了我为了克服和治愈这些创伤而付出的所有努力。尽管很显然，我非常清醒，总是告诉自己：当我看到恶评时，我会想——真可怜。为了做这种事，你的人生一定过得很悲惨吧。
her face look the same, which would be obviously a horrible thing. Why are you commenting it? Why do you think you're doing me a favour? That's what I found so confusing and difficult about the comments is everyone was structuring it and phrasing things when they were commenting these photos in a way as if they were helping me and in a way as if it was out of kindness and like they're a good person. a compliment. Do you think the thing where somebody's like, sorry, I'm like, you cannot even imagine why you would say that. Because it's not like you can change. No. And even if you could,
这就是你用来打发时间的方式。但这次感觉太私人了。感觉完全不同，因为你要付出努力去截取我的脸、裁剪它，然后在评论区留言，你知道的，还要为评论配文或者使用人工智能。你经历了好几个步骤来完成这件事。有很多个时刻，你本可以停下来想想：这或许是个极其糟糕的主意。完全正确。你本来可以在这里拷问一下自己的良知。哪怕你心里这么想，哪怕你觉得：天哪，如果她脸的两边看起来一模一样，那她该有多美啊——这显然是个可怕的想法。为什么要把它发在评论里？为什么你觉得自己是在帮我？这就是我发现这些评论最令人费解、最难以接受的地方：每个人在发布这些照片并发表评论时，他们组织语言和措辞的方式，都表现得好像他们在帮我，表现得好像这是出于善意，表现得像他们是个好人。一种赞美。你觉得那种有人会说“抱歉，我——”的情况是怎样的？你简直无法想象为什么会有人说出那种话。因为这不是说你可以改变的。不。即便你能改变，
why? Why would you say that? So it's basically like, oh, my appearance isn't good enough for your ideas of what pretty is or what it means to be human. So you can erase that half. Yeah. That doesn't fit your standards. And it's also like, oh, you're not, all we care about is, I don't know, making or thinking of you as beautiful. And also, ignoring perhaps the side of your, of your, like, of your chronic illness that is, as we spoke about before. Yeah. Physically, emotionally, socially, really intense. Yeah. And all they're focusing on is wasted potential. Or it was like, um, oh, God, knew you'd be too good looking if my size of your face looked the same. So he had to do that to you.
为什么？为什么要说这种话？所以这基本上就是说：哦，我的外表不符合你对“美丽”或“身为人类”的定义。所以你可以抹去那一半。是的。那部分不符合你的标准。这也好像是在说：哦，你不是——我们唯一关心的就是，我不知道，把你塑造成或认为你是美丽的。而且，这也可能忽略了你的慢性疾病的那一面——正如我们之前所讨论的。是的。在生理、心理、社交上都极其沉重。是的。而他们唯一关注的却是“浪费潜力”。或者就像是：“哦，天哪，早知道你脸的那一边看起来一样，你就会变得太好看了，所以上帝才不得不对你做这种事。”
Oh my God. So when you saw, see those comments, is it rage? is it sadness? Do you have a sense of like, I want to retaliate? Because I feel like those would all be very natural feelings. And I kind of did retaliate with this one. Yeah. I initially was like so confused. I was like, what is going on?
哦天哪。所以当你看到、看到那些评论时，是愤怒？还是悲伤？你会有那种“我想反击”的感觉吗？因为我觉得这些都是非常自然的情绪。而我确实针对这一次进行了反击。是的。我最初感到无比困惑。我当时想：这到底是怎么回事？
Like, how has this become a thing? Just this one post. It's just a video. Like, it's just a normal video. It's not even addressing my appearance. It's just literally two photos. And it's become a trend. Like, it was, I could not go into my comments
这怎么会变成一种现象？仅仅因为这一个帖子。这只是一个视频。就像，这只是一段普通的视频。它甚至都没有谈论我的外表。它只是两张照片而已。而它却变成了一种潮流。就像，我简直无法点进我的评论区
without seeing it. And if it wasn't on that video, it was on other videos. And it's like, then I couldn't even engage with people that were being nice and were my normal followers because of that.
而不看到它。如果那个视频里没有，其他视频里也会有。正因如此，我甚至无法与那些保持友善、作为我正常粉丝的人进行互动。
It was a sea of it. And so initially I was just like, what is going on? Like, I couldn't comprehend it. Like, where it had come from, why people were doing this? And also, why is your brain going to doing that? So many people.
到处都是这种东西。所以起初我只是在想：这到底是怎么回事？就像，我简直无法理解。这到底是从哪里来的，为什么人们要这么做？而且，为什么你们的大脑会去做出这种事？有那么多人。
So many people. And I'm sure a lot of them are children, but that is not an excuse. That is not good enough for me. And so, initially it was confusion and then it was rage and I kind of took a break from social media for a week after it started happening and I sat with it and I wanted to do a video addressing it but I really wanted to kind of come back down from all of these really you know obviously we would
有那么多人在做。而且我确信他们当中很多人是小孩子，但这绝不是借口。这对我来说根本说不通。所以，起初是困惑，然后是愤怒。在那件事开始发酵后，我离开社交媒体休息了一个星期，我静静地坐在那里，想要做一个视频来回应此事，但我真的很想先从所有这些情绪中平复下来——显然，我们总是
like to react and we would like to kind of do things in the moment and I was like I need to give myself a moment to actually work out do I want to give this time do I want to actually make a video addressing this because a lot of comments and haters just want your time and want to be recognized. So I was like, do I actually want to give this the time it doesn't deserve? But I thought this is an issue so much bigger than the comments. This is discrimination. And it's just not good enough. And so, you know, me being like a patron for face equality and all the stuff I do, it felt like I would be doing an injustice if I didn't talk about this. This is such a bigger issue than just me. Yeah. And so I did address it. And it was kind of a lot.
想要去反应，想要在当下做点什么，而我当时对自己说：我需要给自己一点时间来真正弄清楚，我究竟想不想把时间浪费在这上面？我真的想做一个视频来回应吗？因为很多评论者和黑粉只是想要你的时间，想要得到认可。所以我当时在想：我真的要把时间浪费在一个不值得关注的议题上吗？但我觉得这是一个远比评论本身大得多的问题。这是歧视。这绝对是不可接受的。所以，你知道的，作为一个面部平权运动的赞助人以及我所做的一切，如果我不谈论这件事，我会觉得是对正义的背叛。这不仅仅是我个人的问题，而是一个大得多的议题。是的。所以我确实做出了回应。这其中很大一部分内容
about saying like, kind of how dare you? And by you doing this, you are erasing half of me. And actually my condition makes me who I am. It's not who I am. I do things in spite of my condition. But my condition is the reason I am who I am today. It's completely changed me as a person. So by you're racing, that you're racing, what I've been through,
是关于说：怎么敢这样？而通过这样做，你们是在抹去我的一半。事实上，我的病情造就了现在的我。虽然它不是我全部的本质。我克服病情做成了很多事。但我的病情正是我成为今天这个我的原因。它彻底改变了我作为一个人的本质。所以通过抹去这一点，你们抹去了我经历过的一切，
you're erasing, you know, all of the self-work that I've done in one comment, and you don't care. And before you posted that, did you talk to, like, your friends about it, your parents, and what did they say? I can imagine being your parent. They would be like, we don't want any more of this. Yeah, that's, yeah.
你们在一则评论里抹去了我所做过的所有自我建设，而且你们根本不在乎。在你发布那个视频之前，你有没有跟你的朋友、父母谈过这件事？他们是怎么说的？我能想象得到，作为你的父母，他们会说：我们再也不想看到这种东西了。是的，那是，是的。
My mom was quite worried about me posting it. Yeah. Because also at the end I was like, get off my page. And she was like, oh, maybe you shouldn't say that. And I was like, well, no, get off my page, you know. I've never very outspoken like that. I've always been like I never get involved in,
我妈妈很担心我发这个视频。是的。因为最后我也说过：“滚出我的主页。”她就说：“哦，也许你不该这么说。”而我说：“不，滚出我的主页，你知道的。”我从来都不是那种直言不讳的人。我一直都是那种从不参与、
not that this is drama, but I never get involved in controversy. I'm not controversial. I never get involved in drama. And if I speak about issues, it's because they are real issues. And so this felt like it was kind of leaping a little bit out of that box. But it was directly addressing something that I'd been through and an issue today of discrimination, not just a facial difference, but body type, colour, whatever it may be, but in my own way and how it has, you know, affected me. I filmed the video.
倒不是说这是什么抓马，但我从不卷入争议。我不是个有争议的人。我从不卷入抓马。如果我谈论问题，那是因为它们是真实存在的问题。所以这件事感觉有点越界了。但这直接回应了我曾经经历过的事情以及当今存在的歧视问题——不仅仅是面部差异，还包括体型、肤色或其他任何事情，但我是在用我自己的方式，以及它如何，你知道的，影响了我。我拍了这段视频。
I kind of had a few talking points because I was like, I want this to be as dual-ended as possible. I want to adjust the fact that this isn't okay, but also kind of be like, get off my page, end it with a positive. So I really wanted to sit there and think, like, okay, how do I want to structure this? I kind of let myself just speak from the heart, but also I wanted to relay things in the best way I could. And I sent it to my friend, one of my best friends, and she was like, this is amazing. Post it. And when I posted it, I was so anxious, I was like, oh, no, maybe I should have posted it. And that video's got 10 million views on TikTok about me addressing it.
我准备了一些谈话要点，因为我想让视频尽可能做到双管齐下。我想要强调这种行为是不可接受的，但同时也想顺便说一句“滚出我的主页”，并以积极的方式结尾。所以我真的很想坐在那里思考：好吧，我到底该如何构建这段内容？我任由自己发自内心地去表达，但我也希望以我所能达到的最好方式来传达这些事情。我把它发给了我的朋友，我最好的朋友之一，她说：“这太棒了。发吧。”当我把它发出去的时候，我焦虑极了，心想：哦不，也许我不该发这个。那个关于我回应此事的TikTok视频获得了1000万的浏览量。
And thousands of comments on Instagram with people, you know, followers and people saying, I cannot believe people are doing this. And so if anything, it actually helped people, even now, if people comment that on my videos, other people say, why are you doing this? She said she doesn't like it and this isn't okay. So it's kind of created more allyship, I feel like, and also made people that don't have a facial difference
Instagram上也有成千上万的评论，粉丝们和路人们纷纷表示：“我简直不敢相信有人会做这种事。”所以如果说有什么不同的话，它实际上起到了帮助作用——甚至到现在，如果有人在我的视频里发这种评论，其他人也会说：“你为什么要这么做？她说她不喜欢这样，这根本不可接受。”所以我觉得这创造了更多的盟友关系，同时也让那些没有面部差异
or a bodily difference, aware of a really big issue on social media. But it's also, it's down to the social media apps. They're not doing enough. And that's my constant, like, paradox as well. with using social media. So I'm like, you're not doing enough to support people like me. Also, they make so much money off of views, likes, engagement, off of the reputation that you give platforms of like,
或身体差异的人意识到社交媒体上存在的一个非常严重的问题。但归根结底，这也取决于社交媒体应用程序。他们做得还远远不够。这也是我在使用社交媒体时不断面临的悖论。因为我会想：你们在支持像我这样的人方面做得还不够。同时，他们又通过浏览量、点赞数、互动量赚了那么多钱，凭借你们这些平台赋予的名誉——
you are somebody who goes to the Oscars, somebody who goes to Cannes, somebody who does this, you have legitimized social media as a business that benefits them and then they'll just let people tear into you and do nothing about it. So that's also really disheartening with, And I get it's such a big issue and it takes so many people to change almost the most minute thing when it's such a big company or, you know, tech. But equally, when this is such a big issue and it's so rampant in so many ways, not just for people's facial differences,
比如，你是一个去过奥斯卡的人，一个去过戛纳的人，一个做过这些事的人，你让社交媒体合法化为一笔有利于他们的生意，然后他们却任由别人对你进行人身攻击，却什么都不做。这同样让人感到十分沮丧，与……而且我明白这是一个非常宏大的问题，当涉及到如此庞大的公司或科技企业时，改变哪怕最微小的细节都需要许许多多的人共同努力。但同样地，当这是一个如此重大且在许多方面如此猖獗的问题时——不仅仅针对面部差异，
there should be more in place to give people more authority and more control over their accounts to be able to enjoy social media and enjoy posting and not fear the backlash. Because that is not free speech, that is hate and that is discrimination. Yeah, absolutely. I feel like you've handled that in just like the most amazing way. I tried. Yeah, I think you deserve a lot of credit for it. Thank you. That's fucking hard. Yeah. And you were like, well, you were what, 20 when that happened? Yeah, and it's also just such like an unforeseen thing. Like, I've never seen anyone deal with that at such a large scale. So I was also just like, I don't know how to deal with this, how to take this, how to respond. Yeah, now that you say it,
应该有更多的机制来赋予人们对其账号更多的管理权和控制权，让他们能够享受社交媒体和发帖的乐趣，而不必害怕遭遇网暴。因为那不是言论自由，那是仇恨，那是歧视。是的，完全如此。我觉得你以最了不起的方式处理了这件事。我尽量。是的，我认为你为此值得很多赞赏。谢谢。这真的太难了。是的。而且你当时，呃，你发生那件事的时候多大？20岁？是的，而且这也是一件完全意料之外的事。就像，我从来没见过任何人经历过这么大范围的网暴。所以我当时也只是在想：我不知道该怎么处理这件事，该怎么承受，该怎么回应。是的，现在经你这么一说，
it's like I've never, I've never seen anything like that. No. And obviously, like, people get trolled when they've like in at the center of drama yeah or something's happened but for it to be that individual and personal and for you to be going through that at 20 and just being like completely like unprovoked like just a normal innocent TikTok yeah I'm glad people are a kind of now they can police it for you yeah and now they can be like get out get the fuck out of here exactly because I think that's the thing is there is I feel like we will have a lack of like allyship on social media and also in life i think we all need to be more supportive of one another and i completely get life happens and obviously you're focusing on like your shit and you know it's
感觉就像我从未、从未见过类似的事情。没有。显然，人们在卷入抓马的中心或发生了什么事情时会遭到网暴，但对于这种如此针对个人、针对你本人、而且在你20岁时经历这一切、完全是无妄之灾——仅仅是一段普通、无辜的TikTok视频。是的，我很高兴人们现在成了一种力量，他们可以为你维护秩序，现在他们可以说“滚开，他妈的从这儿滚开”，完全正确。因为我认为关键在于，我感觉我们在社交媒体乃至生活中都缺乏这种盟友关系。我认为我们所有人都需要对彼此更加支持，我完全理解生活总是在继续，显然你都在专注于自己的一地鸡毛，你知道的，
always tunnel vision i'm like that but you shouldn't have to like people that are going through the issue whatever it is discrimination um misogy misogyny whatever it is they shouldn't have to be the ones that are constantly speaking about the issue it should be the people around them that are less affected by the issue that are also speaking about it and, you know, pushing that along and voicing it and amplifying the voice. So that's what I talk a lot about with, you know, facial difference advocacy is like being an ally is literally just supporting the message and saying like, this isn't okay or why are you doing that. And so that is one beautiful thing about what has come out of social media is as much as I can obviously say, this isn't good, this isn't
总是带着隧道视野，我就是那样的人。但你本不该承受——无论遭遇什么问题的人，无论是歧视、厌女症还是其他任何问题，他们都不应该是那些不断谈论这个问题的人。应该是由他们周围那些受该问题影响较小的人也在谈论这个问题，
good. I obviously spend most of my life on it because it is my job. And so, there is a beauty in the community I've built. And also, I have gone from being stared out on the street because of my appearance only on face value, whereas when I was younger, whereas now I get stared out on the street mainly because people recognize me. Wow. So that's been a really beautiful shift. And is it nice as well to feel like if somebody's looking at you, you can be like, yeah, it's because of that. Yeah.
并且推动事情发展，发出声音并放大这种声音。这就是我在谈论面部差异倡导时经常说的：成为一名盟友实际上就是支持这一信息，并说“这不可接受”或“你为什么要这么做”。所以，从社交媒体中产生的一件美好的事情是——尽管我显然可以说“这不好，那不好”，但我的大部分生活显然都花在上面，因为这是我的工作。因此，我在其中建立的社群中也存在着美好之处。而且，我过去常常因为仅仅停留在外表层面的面部特征而在街上被人行注目礼，那是我更小的时候；而现在，我在街上被人行注目礼主要是因为人们认出了我。哇。所以这是一个非常美好的转变。而且，如果有人在看着你，你能感觉到“是的，是因为这个”，这种感觉是不是也挺好的？是的。
It's because of this other reason. Yeah, it's not always that. I'm not like, oh, you know me, like instantly. but I do feel like it's beautiful now because they'll make me see my condition and that's like how they know it's Nicky. But it's like they see Nikki. And I think that's what's beautiful is I've spent so much of my life only being seen as my condition, by doctors, by myself, by people on the street, peers, whatever it may be. It's been really beautiful to be able to change that narrative through what I do with especially kids and young people as like I am Nikki Lilly. Nikki, I'm not, oh, the girl with the medical condition.
是因为这个其他的原因。是的，并不总是那样。我不是那种“哦，你认识我”的瞬间反应。但我确实觉得现在很美好，因为他们会看到我的病情，那是他们认出这是尼基的方式。但他们看到的是尼基。我认为美好之处在于，我生命中的大部分时间都仅仅被视为我的病情——被医生、被我自己、被街上的人、同龄人，无论是什么人。能够通过我所做的事情来改变这种叙事，特别是对于孩子们和年轻人来说，真的非常美好，我是尼基·莉莉。尼基，我不是“哦，那个有医疗状况的女孩”。
Yeah. So when people recognize me now, they're just coming up to me and saying like, oh, I love you, please, can I have a photo? Oh, cool. And that's been really special because I spent so much of my life hiding myself. Like even now, I, from very early age, internalize, like, things to do when I walk past a big group of people. I would, like, do this and scratch my head to, you know, pretend that I've got an it
所以现在当人们认出我时，他们只是走到我面前说：“哦，我好喜欢你，求你了，能合个影吗？”哦，太酷了。这真的非常特别，因为我生命中的大部分时间都在隐藏自己。甚至到现在，我从很小的时候就内化了一种习惯，比如当我走过一大群人时要做的事情。我会像这样抓抓头，你知道的，假装我头皮发痒，
so it covers my eye when I'm going through a busy place. Like, I still do it. Really? Yeah. Wow. It's so internalized. You have the desire to help to make a real difference?
这样当我穿过拥挤的地方时，它就能挡住我的眼睛。就像，我到现在还会这样做。真的吗？是的。哇。这已经深入骨髓了。你有想要提供切实帮助、带来真正改变的愿望吗？
The College of the City you offer the program Dependence and Scenti Mental. Acquare the competences essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the difficulties of
城市学院为您提供“依赖与心理健康”项目。掌握陪伴和支持面临困难的人群所必需的核心能力，
and to build a career enrichisante to service of the community francophone of all the country. Donnay
为全国的法语社群服务，开启一段丰富充实的事业生涯。提供
of the quality in French, it's possible with the City. Visit Collage Lacit LacitonC. DEMENT,
优质的法语服务，在城市学院一切皆有可能。请访问 Collage Lacit LacitonC. DEMENT，
an initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Santet ...sought new moment it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified.
这是国家健康法语培训联盟的一项倡议……在某个时刻，感觉它仿佛无休止地延续下去。我当时以为自己活不成了。我吓坏了。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child.
那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变全黑了。这把我吓了个半死。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以毫不夸张地说，这是你职业生涯中最大的一起案件？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀一个孩子。
She's as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one of the one. and saw the murder take place by creveth and de pippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief.
她简直是罪大恶极。我想是的。人们醒醒吧。我是其中之一。并目睹了由克雷维特和德皮波实施的谋杀过程。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出任何悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我会把它告上法庭。
Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Kotby host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer,
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Devil's Quarry》。要想无广告收听《The Devil's Quarry》并获取独家内容，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅LaVa for Good Plus。我是《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb》播客的主持人霍达·科特布（Hoda Kotb）。在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话，比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战：我曾经历过乳腺癌，后来又帮助母亲战胜乳腺癌，
and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And he's a ton of exciting because their new star is Javier Cichorino Hernandez. He's from Mexico. He was going to do shit. Everyone sees me as a football player.
而那要艰难得多。许多人了解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb》。他非常让人兴奋，因为他们的超级新星是哈维尔·“奇查里托”·埃尔南德斯（Javier "Chicharito" Hernandez）。他来自墨西哥。他本来打算大干一场。每个人都把我当成足球运动员。
But before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist?
但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共存。我依然有那么多的疑问。我们从哪里来？人死后会发生什么？你如何应对被全网抵制？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？
What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extreme. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just.
什么是爱情？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常平凡到深刻极端。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈，脆弱感在这里流露。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标与人生教训在此分享。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。
Wait-in me, I'm here to put me going to be able to be able to be. The Chicharito. I'm Javier El Chicharito-R-Landes and together with Ica Radio. We're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
等等，我在这里……哈维尔·埃尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯，我和IHeartRadio一起，将让平凡变得不平凡。保持关注。这太棒了。哇。请在IHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learning to Be Human》。
Mainstream media is full of crude depictions of the unhoused, stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The Un House is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator and host. And for years, I've created a space where the unhouse and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. Woody Enhous is a two-time webby and signal award-winning show with many exciting guests on the
主流媒体充斥着对无家可归者的粗暴描绘，这些故事充满羞耻与指责，将无家可归者脸谱化为一个单一群体。《We The Unhoused》是一档正在改变这一现状的播客。我是创始人兼主持人西奥·亨德森（Theo Henderson）。多年来，我创造了一个空间，让无家可归者和他们的倡导者能够讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去几个月里，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQIA+群体，以及那些制定影响无家可归者生存状态法律的决策者。《We The Unhoused》是一档曾两次荣获威比奖（Webby）和信号奖（Signal Award）的节目，未来还将迎来许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。
horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill Whittler, a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online. and in her community. Listen to Wey and Howls on the I-Hard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. You went to the Oscars.
本周请收听我对吉尔·威特勒（Jill Whittler）博士的采访，她是一位由街头医生转型的网红，她对无家可归者社区的工作在网络和她的社区中产生了巨大的影响。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《We The Unhoused》。你去了奥斯卡颁奖典礼。
I know. Crazy. Crazy. Yeah. Do you want to talk about that? Let's do it. When you were there, did you have that impulse? I was so anxious about the Oscars because, firstly, I was like,
我知道。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。是的。你想聊聊这个吗？我们聊聊吧。你在那里的时候，有没有那种冲动？我对奥斯卡感到非常焦虑，因为首先我觉得，
I'm not an actor, don't know why I'm here. Like, I had such bad imposter syndrome. Honestly, they invite so many people who are just doing amazing things in all different spaces. Exactly. So the Oscars have 25 spaces to fill every year that are outside of cast, crew, and, you know, other people that go to the Oscars. And I was one of those 25 globally. I think I was the only person from the UK. And so it's like you and your plus one, which is who'd you bring? Insane. I just brought my manager. Boring. I honestly, I, no offense to my manager,
我不是演员，不知道自己为什么会在这里。比如，我有很严重的老年痴说综合征（译注：此处应为“冒名顶替综合征”）。老实说，他们邀请了那么多在各个领域做着了不起事情的人。完全正确。所以奥斯卡每年有25个名额留给演员、剧组人员以及你知道的去奥斯卡的其他人员之外的人。我是全球这25个人之一。我想我是唯一来自英国的人。所以就像是你和你的女伴/男伴，你带了谁？太疯狂了。我只带了我的经纪人。真无聊。老实说，我，对我的经纪人没有恶意，
I would have loved to have brung like a friend or a family member. But I knew that my manager would be the most supportive in that high pressure environment. Like, he can navigate the room for me because I knew that if I bring, like, a family member or a friend, I'm then having to worry about, okay, where do I need to go? Where is the carpet? Whereas, like, he can assert that because he is my manager. It's his job. Yeah.
我本来很想带一个朋友或家庭成员去的。但我知道在那种高压环境下，我的经纪人会给予我最大的支持。比如，他能为我应付场面，因为我知道如果我带了家庭成员或朋友，我就不得不开始操心：好吧，我需要去哪里？红毯在哪里？而他可以理所当然地处理这些，因为他是我的经纪人。这是他的工作。是的。
Yeah. So I was like, you know what? It's probably the best idea to do that. But I brought my best friend with me to LA. Okay. So, like, the surrounding experience was with her. And we went to like an after party to get the, but. Which after party?
是的。所以我想，你知道吗？这样做可能是最好的主意。但我把我的最好朋友带到了洛杉矶。所以，整个周边的体验是和她一起的。我们去了某个派对的after party，为了……哪个after party？
Elton John's after party. But he wasn't there. Wait, what? I know. He can't call it Elton John's after party if Elton John isn't there. Exactly. It's like calling it a Taylor Swift concert and she's not performing. No, honestly, I think he'd like, we got there pretty late because I had to go back to the hotel and like change because I couldn't have won that dress to the party.
埃尔顿·约翰（Elton John）的after party。但他不在那儿。等等，什么？我知道。如果埃尔顿·约翰不在，就不能叫埃尔顿·约翰的after party。没错。这就好比举办一场泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）的演唱会，而她根本不表演一样。不，说实话，我觉得他……我们到得很晚，因为我不得不回酒店换衣服，因为我不能穿着那条裙子去派对。
The white dress. Yeah. It's gorgeous, by the way. Oh, thank you. It would have gotten dirty, though, I feel like. Exactly. Even the bottom of it was getting dirty. Just went off on the street.
那条白裙子。是的。顺便说一句，美极了。哦，谢谢。不过我觉得它会弄脏的。没错。连裙摆都在变脏。直接在街上拖着。
Who were you wearing? So it's a brand called Lou Chen. She actually has a dress in the Met Gala this year, which I was. is pregnant. Whoa, cool. She turned that dress around in a week. Go and look up this dress. It's mind-blowing.
你穿的是哪个牌子的？是一个叫刘辰（Lou Chen）的品牌。她今年甚至在Met Gala上有一件礼服，当时我……怀孕了。哇，太酷了。她在一周内就把那条裙子赶制出来了。去搜搜这条裙子。太震撼了。
It's like a wedding dress level of just like crazy couture beauty. Yeah, it's, I don't know how she did it. I was kind of anxious because I've never done a custom dress before. And obviously, when you're doing something like that, you have to wear that dress. Someone spent their time and their effort on it. Yeah, you can't just go and get something else. No, but I'm so used to having options and options make me feel safe because I'm like, we've got plan A, plan B, plan C.
就像婚纱级别的疯狂高级定制美学。是的，我不知道她是怎么做到的。我有点焦虑，因为我从来没有做过定制礼服。显而易见，当你做这样的事情时，你必须穿那条裙子。有人在上面花时间和精力了。是的，你不能随随便便去换别的。不，但我太习惯有很多选择了，选择让我感到安全，因为我会想：我们有A计划、B计划、C计划。
So for this, it was like, I was putting all my eggs in one basket and being like, well, this is what I'm wearing? And because it was the Oscars, I was like, but what if I don't like it? What if it's not perfect? It was perfect. And I couldn't have been happier with it. And because it was custom, I can now keep it. So I can, if I ever have children or like, whatever, I can be like, this is what I wore to
所以对于这个，感觉就像是我把所有的鸡蛋都放在一个篮子里，然后想：好吧，这就是我要穿的？而且因为是奥斯卡，我就想：万一我不喜欢它呢？万一它不完美呢？它非常完美。我对它满意得不能再满意了。而且因为是定制的，我现在可以保留它。所以我可以，如果我以后有了孩子或者别的什么，我可以像这样说：这就是我穿去
the Oscars. It's like my wedding dress. Oh my God. That is the coolest freaking thing. Yeah. Because normally you don't get to keep the dress. You have to give it back. Exactly.
奥斯卡的衣服。就像我的婚纱一样。天哪。这简直是史上最酷的事情。是的。因为通常你不能保留这条裙子。你必须把它还回去。没错。
Yeah. That's the thing I don't think people get is like. Like everything you're giving back, like, if you're not a brand. They ain't for you. No. But, yeah, the Oscars was phenomenal. I, like, I blacked out. I was so anxious from the moment I, to be honest, from the moment I woke up that day.
是的。我觉得大家不明白的一点是。就像你交还的所有东西一样，如果你不是这个品牌的人。它们就不属于你。不。但是，是的，奥斯卡太棒了。我，就像，我断片了。从我，老实说，从我那天醒来的那一刻起我就很焦虑。
I was so anxious. I woke up at 7 a.m. Because I had to be ready by midday. Wow. Really early. The Oscars is like, you're sat by four for the, you know, for the Oscars. So you have to get there. It takes an hour because of the traffic because they shut down L.A.
我太焦虑了。我早上7点就醒了。因为我必须在中午前准备好。哇。真的很早。奥斯卡颁奖典礼就像是，你4点钟就得坐好，为了（你知道的）奥斯卡。所以你必须赶到那里。由于交通原因，花了一个小时，因为他们封锁了洛杉矶。
Yeah, because where is it? Is it the Chinese? It's the, I think it's the Dolby Theater. be theatre. Yeah. So it's like a big, I mean, St. Oscar's a massive deal. But I was so anxious. Like, I was, we were in the car on the way and I was like, I can't do this. Like, I was, I thought I was going to be sick. Really? No, honestly, I, whenever I do something like that, it may seem like, can or whatever, it may seem like I'm fine. I am like having the biggest panic attack of my life inside. Really? I black out. In the car. I blacked out from the
是的，因为在哪里？是那个中国剧院吗？是，我想那是杜比剧院。杜比剧院。是的。所以这是一个大型的——我的意思是，奥斯卡是一件大事。但我太焦虑了。就像，我们在车上在去的路上，我心想：我做不到。我以为我要吐了。真的吗？不，老实说，每当我做类似的事情时，可能看起来，或者别的什么，可能看起来我很好。我内心其实正在经历我一生中最严重的恐慌发作。真的吗？我断片了。在车里。从我
moment. I got in the car on the way there to the moment we sat down. Like the whole of the red car, it I barely remember. Okay, the fact that you cannot remember and you, the, you looked that amazing, just because like the poses you, like, you were like, your body took over and you, like, I know exactly how to look. I don't really. Yeah. I don't know what did. But I think my body almost went into like, fight, flight, or freeze and it's just like, okay, we need to get through this. Or four and you were like, I know exactly what I'm doing. Yeah, no, I blacked out. But I think whenever something like that happens, all I want is for it to just go well and everything to a line and because there was such a big buildup, I knew since November I was going. I actually
上车去那里的那一刻起，直到我们坐下的那一刻，我全断片了。就像整个红毯，我几乎都不记得了。好吧，鉴于你不记得了，而且你看起来那么惊艳，仅仅是因为你摆姿势的样子……就像你的身体接管了一切，你知道该怎么看镜头。其实我不知道。是的。我不知道自己是怎么做到的。但我觉得我的身体几乎进入了战斗、逃跑或僵住的状态，它只是在说：好吧，我们需要度过这一关。而你却表现得好像你知道自己在做什么。是的，不，我断片了。但我觉得每当这种事情发生时，我所希望的只是它能顺利进行，一切都能配合好，而且因为有这么长时间的铺垫，我从11月起就知道我要去了。我其实
couldn't, it kind of did for like a wedding where it's like, you know there's this massive date and this massive day and you're kind of like, everything needs to work out so this all kind of goes smoothly and, you know, this could be the one time I do it in my life, like a wedding, so let's make it count. Yeah. So I was just like, please let everything go well for me for once. And it did. It couldn't have gone better than I imagined. And it was honestly amazing. Like we had such amazing seats and I could see like the back of Timothy Shannamay's head like yeah okay wait wait wait I have I have three follow-up questions are you ready number one what did you eat what do they give you on terms of food and drink okay so when you're there in the theatre they give you a snack box
感觉这有点像婚礼，你知道有一个巨大的日子和一个巨大的日子，你就会觉得：一切都需要顺利进行，这样才能万事大吉，你知道的，这可能是我一生中唯一一次做这件事，就像婚礼一样，所以让我们让它意义非凡。是的。所以我当时就想：求求了，让一切为我顺利一次吧。结果确实如此。它比我想象的还要完美。而且老实说太棒了。我们有非常棒的座位，我甚至能看到蒂莫西·柴勒梅德（Timothy Chalamet）的后脑勺。等等，等等，等等，我有三个后续问题，你准备好了吗？第一，你吃了什么？在食物和饮料方面他们给了你什么？好吧，当你在剧院里时，他们会给你一个零食盒，
under your under your chair and it had like chocolate in it it had popcorn in it and it has a drink that's all you get for the ceremony but it's like the oscar snack box um oh my god I found this new chocolate that I was obsessed with and then I couldn't find it anywhere that I It's a cut. Snow caps. So their chocolate chips covered in sprinkles. And you just, like, pull them out and they are insane. So I finished, like, because I hadn't eaten all day.
放在你的座位底下，里面有巧克力，有爆米花，还有一杯饮料。这就是典礼期间你所有的东西，但就像是奥斯卡零食盒。哦天哪，我发现了这种让我痴迷的新巧克力，然后我到处都找不到它。是Snow Caps。它们是裹着彩色糖针的巧克力豆。你只要像这样拿出来，它们简直绝了。所以我吃完了，因为我一整天都没吃东西。
Whenever I'm anxious, I don't eat. Yeah. It's like, my body is like, you can't eat until this is done. It's like it just tenses up and freezes up. I'm like the opposite of, like, a comfort eater. I'm like, I can't eat when I'm stressed. So I ate at, like, midnight that night. But so you get a snack box, and that's just it at the Oscars,
每当我焦虑的时候，我就不吃东西。是的。我的身体就像是：在事情搞定之前你不能吃东西。它就像是绷紧并冻结了。我跟那种情绪性进食者恰好相反。我会觉得：压力大的时候我吃不下。所以我那天晚上半夜才吃东西。但总之你会得到一个零食盒，在奥斯卡这就是全部了，
because obviously you're not on tables. You're, like, in a theater, like a cinema. And everyone that's so funny, like, at the front, they're all there eating their snacks in between, like, the main... Like, Timothy Shalmers, like, eating his snow caps. Yeah, there's this photo of, like, Teana Taylor, who's an actress. And she's got, like, her snack box, like, on the floor. And she's, like, in this, like, photo. And it just makes it all seem so much more, like, funny and real light.
因为很显然你们不是坐在桌子旁。你们是在剧院里，就像电影院一样。每个人都……太搞笑了，在前排，他们在主节目间隙坐在那里吃零食……就像蒂莫西·柴勒梅德在吃他的Snow Caps。对，有一张照片，比如演员蒂亚娜·泰勒（Teyana Taylor）。她把零食盒放在地板上。她拍了这样一张照片。这让这一切看起来滑稽且真实得多。
I mean, people got to eat, you know? That is crazy because I was, like, and it's a long. It's, like, four hours, right? Very long. But after, they have something called the Governor's Ball. and it's like in a separate room and that's where the Oscars winners get their name engraved on their Oscar
我的意思是，人总得吃饭，对吧？这太疯狂了，因为我想，而且时间很长。大概四个小时，对吧？非常长。但之后，他们有一个叫做州长舞会（Governor's Ball）的活动，
because obviously they don't know who's going to win so they only put it on after. The spread of food was crazy. So they have Wolfgang Puck, who's a chef, like, do all the food. And it was like tables of food. They had a whole dessert table. They had a whole hot food table.
在一个独立的房间里，奥斯卡得主们会在那里把他们的名字刻在小金人上，因为很显然他们不知道谁会赢，所以只有在结果揭晓后才会刻上去。食物的种类疯狂至极。他们请了主厨沃尔夫冈·帕克（Wolfgang Puck）来准备所有的食物。到处都是摆满食物的桌子。他们有一整张甜点桌。他们有一整张热食桌。
They had a whole ice cream section. And I feel like I didn't enjoy it probably because I was in this white dress. Like I cannot get anything on this. Yeah, you can't. I've got a full face of makeup and I've got extensions and this is not the vibe to be like indulging in food. Dude, I love how I'm like, so what was, what are you eating? Also, if somebody's... I mean, I had a little burger. I sat down. I had a burger and I had a hot dog and I had an ice cream.
他们还有一整块冰淇淋区。我觉得我可能没有好好享受它，因为我穿着这件白裙子。我绝对不能把任何东西弄到上面。是的，你不能。我化了全妆，还接了头发，这可不是大吃大喝的氛围。天哪，我太喜欢我这种状态了：“那么，你在吃什么？”而且如果有人……我的意思是，我吃了一个小汉堡。我坐下来。我吃了一个汉堡，一个热狗，还有一个冰淇淋。
Yeah. But it was so funny. Me and my manager were like perched on the end of this sofa with like some Oscars winners and the Oscars was just on the table. We were just like sat in silence and I was just eating my burger. Oh my God. Well, this brings me to my next question. So first question was food was good, but you didn't really have much. because you were anxious. What I had was good. Yeah, you had a little, a little bit. A little bit. Who were you the most shell-shocked to meet?
是的。但太搞笑了。我和我的经纪人像两只鸟儿一样栖息在这个沙发的边缘，旁边坐着一些奥斯卡得主，奥斯卡奖杯就放在桌子上。我们就那样静静地坐着，而我正在吃我的汉堡。天哪。好吧，这让我想到了我的下一个问题。所以第一个问题是食物很好，但你其实没吃多少，因为你很焦虑。我吃的那些很好。是的，你吃了一点点。一点点。见到谁让你最震惊？
So I didn't meet that many people because when you do the carpet especially, you're given time slots to go on. Yeah. So it kind of runs like a well-oiled machine. It's like, you know, a smooth run, not like a massive cure of people on the carpet. I was really, like, excited to meet, you know, Amelia de Moldenberg, who does chicken shop date because she does the interviews on the carpet. So that was really cool.
其实我没遇到多少人，因为特别是当你在走红毯时，你是有被分配时间段的。是的。所以它就像一台运转良好的机器一样运行。非常顺畅，红毯上不会挤满一大群人。我真的很兴奋能见到阿米莉亚·迪姆尔德伯格（Amelia Dimoldenberg），也就是“鸡店约会”（Chicken Shop Date）的主持人，因为她在红毯上做采访。所以那真的很酷。
Did you like to do you with her? Yeah. I did one which is really... Oh my God. And like the Academy, like, posted it and it was crazy. So that was really cool. That's very full circle. But McKenna Grace, who's an actress.
你和她一起做采访了吗？是的。我做了一个，真的……天哪。学院（The Academy）甚至还把它发出来了，太疯狂了。所以那真的很酷。这非常有宿命感。还有麦肯娜·格瑞丝（Mckenna Grace），她是一位演员。
She's going to be in the New Hunger Games. She's going to be Daphne in like Scooby-Doo. She's in Five Nights of Freddy, so many other things. She's amazing. She's like a young actress. She's 19, which is... She is also the girl who was like, she was every single younger version of any blonde character in every single movie.
她将出演新的《饥饿游戏》。她将在《史酷比》中饰演达芙妮（Daphne）。她还演过《玩具熊的五夜后宫》以及其他好多作品。她太棒了。她是一位年轻演员。她19岁，这……她也是那个女孩，几乎承包了每一部电影里所有金发角色的童年时期。
Yeah, that's so true. I think she's been in like the most franchised films ever. Yeah. I can imagine. She's what a life. Like the American young actors and actresses, I don't know what they're eating. I know what they're doing. It's just different.
是的，太对了。我觉得她演过最多的系列电影了吧。是的，我可以想象。这就是生活。美国的年轻男女演员，我不知道他们在吃什么。我知道他们在做什么。就是不一样。
Yeah. But she was so sweet. She came up to me. And again, I was like, I'm not an actress. I don't know what I'm doing here. Like, you know, did the carpet. I was so anxious for the carpet as well because it was my first ever carpet in the US period. So I was like, I don't know, with my appearance, I don't know how the photography.
是的。但她人太好了。她朝我走过来。同样，我又觉得：我不是演员，我不知道自己在这里做什么。就像，走完红毯。对于红毯我也感到非常焦虑，因为这是我平生第一次在美国走红毯。所以我当时想：我不知道，以我的外表，摄影师会怎么看我。
are going to perceive me. I don't know how the press is going to take me or respond to me. Yeah, I was just very anxious. It was the same when I went to Cannes and I was like, I don't know what it's going to be like on the carpet. I just, you don't know. It's not familiar. But everyone was so lovely and they had like a crowd of like young people who
我不知道媒体会怎么接受我或对我做出什么反应。是的，我当时非常焦虑。我去戛纳的时候也是这样，我想：我不知道红毯上会是什么样。你就是不知道。这很陌生。但每个人都太好了，他们有一群年轻人，
were like cheering for everyone that came in. So when I walked in, they were like cheering for me. And I just did not know what to do with myself. I was so awkwardly like. And they probably knew who you were as well. Yeah. But for me, I'm like, oh, they were cheering for everyone. It's not me.
为每一个进场的人欢呼。所以当我走进去的时候，他们为我欢呼。我简直不知道该拿自己怎么办。我尴尬得……他们可能也知道你是谁。是的。但对我来说，我会想：哦，他们在为每个人欢呼。不是我。
You know, I'm just like that. But McCrani Gray, sorry, back to that. Yeah. She came up to me and was like, hi, I just want to say, like, me trying to do an American accent of her. Hi, I just want to say, I love your videos. And I was like, because I really wanted to go, you know who I am, but I was like, let me not do that.
你知道，我就是这样的人。不过说回麦肯娜·格瑞丝，抱歉，回到正题。是的。她朝我走过来，然后说：嗨，我只是想说，（模仿她说话）——我在试图模仿她的美国口音。嗨，我只想说，我喜欢你的视频。我当时就想——因为我真的很想说“你知道我是谁”，但我觉得：别这么做。
Let me, you know, act like I can meet her on that level. So I was like, oh my God, thank you so much. She looked like a princess because she did. She had this amazing pink dress. And then we were just saying it was so hot because that day it was 35 degrees, see? And it was outdoors carpet. We were all in like the most heavy dresses
让我，你知道的，表现得好像我可以和她在同一个水平线上交流。所以我说：哦天哪，太感谢了。她看起来就像个公主，因为她确实是。她穿着一件令人惊叹的粉红色裙子。然后我们就在说天气太热了，因为那天温度高达35度。而且是户外的红毯。我们都穿着厚重的礼服，
full face and makeup dying. All of the Oscar's workers had like those neck fans around them. Oh my God, the Dyson. It was, yeah, it was so hot. So we were like, are you dying? Yeah, are you dying? Yeah. She was so sweet.
画着全妆，快热死了。所有奥斯卡的工作人员脖子上都挂着那种挂脖小风扇。天哪，戴森的。天气确实太热了。所以我们就说：你快热死了吗？是的，你快死了吗？是的。她太友好了。
We spoke for a few minutes and I was like, how are you feeling? She was like, I'm really nervous, but I'm excited to be here. I'm just so sweet. and that was something that was so crazy because I also forget people, obviously I know I've got a lot of followers, but you do just, I'm sure you feel the same,
我们聊了几分钟，我问：你感觉怎么样？她说：我真的很紧张，但能来这里我很兴奋。她人真的太好了。这让我觉得非常疯狂，因为我也经常忘记——当然我知道我有很多粉丝，但你确实会，我相信你也有同感，
you do just think that as a number. You forget every one of those are people, and those people aren't just in the UK or Australia, they are all across the world. So then when she said, like, oh, I love your videos, I was like, you're in America, you're an incredible actress, and you know who I am, it was this really strange, like, and also the fact that, like, what I think acting is such a legitimate job
你往往会把他们当成一个数字。你忘记了他们每个人都是活生生的人，而这些人不仅仅在英国或澳大利亚，他们遍布全世界。所以当她说“哦，我喜欢你的视频”时，我就觉得：你在美国，你是一个不可思议的演员，而你竟然知道我是谁！这是一种非常奇怪的……而且事实上，我觉得演戏是一份非常正经的工作，而有时做自媒体可能会让人觉得没那么正经、没那么真实或重要。所以对我来说，这是一种非常诡异的感觉，就像她认可了我在做的事情并给予了肯定，这给了我一些信心，我觉得。是的，所以她就是那个……人太好了。是的，所以埃尔顿·约翰的after party很有趣，非常非常有趣。你在那里看到什么酷的人了吗？有一个我非常迷恋的系列剧叫《告诉我谎言》（Tell Me Lies）。我听说过这个，昨天有人让我去看看。我觉得你应该看一看，因为里面有很多心理学方面的东西。我觉得你会觉得：是的，这人脑子有毛病。
and sometimes doing social media can feel a little bit less legitimate or like real or like important and so for me it was this really weird thing where it's like she recognized what I was doing and kind of validated it and then that gave me a bit of like confidence I think yeah so she was she was like the one so sweet yeah so the Elton John after party was fun very very fun did you see anybody cool there so there's a series I'm obsessed with called tell me lies I've heard about this somebody told me to watch this yesterday I feel like you should watch it because there's a lot of psychological stuff in it. I feel like you'd be like, yeah, he's got this wrong with him.
有时做社交媒体会让人觉得没那么正统，或者没那么真实、没那么重要，所以对我来说这是一件很奇妙的事情，就好像她认可了我在做的事情并给予了某种肯定，这给了我一些信心，我想是的，所以她就像是那个特别温柔的人，是的。所以埃尔顿·约翰的会后派对很有趣，非常非常有趣。你在那儿看到什么酷的人了吗？有一个我着迷的系列剧叫《告诉谎言》。我听说过这个，昨天有人叫我去看。我觉得你应该看看，因为里面有很多心理学方面的东西。我觉得你会觉得，是的，这人这方面有问题。
Like, I feel like you'd really enjoy it. Is it like reality TV? No. Oh, okay, okay. Oh, it's amazing. You should watch it. So some of the cast was there. And I wasn't like, I was too, I'm not, I don't really drink at all, but I was too
就像，我觉得你会非常喜欢它。是那种真人秀吗？不是。哦，好吧，好吧。哦，它太棒了。你应该去看看。所以其中一些演员也在那儿。我并没有……我其实根本不怎么喝酒，但我太
sober to go up to them and like, be like, hi. Yeah. Because I was so anxious. I like didn't, you know, during anything that day. But yeah, we saw them. Who else did we see? We saw. Milo Mannheim, who's going to be the new Flim Rider in The Tangled that's coming out.
清醒了，不敢走过去跟他们打招呼。是的。因为我太焦虑了。那天我什么都没……你知道的。不过是的，我们看到他们了。我们还看到了谁？我们看到了
Dude, you just got the full young Hollywood show. That was exactly it. It was all of the young Hollywood, like, people, which is really crazy. My best friend, like, Alicia, who... She came with you, right? She came with me. We snuck her in. She's obsessed with Miano Mannheim.
米洛·曼海姆（Milo Manheim），他将是即将在上映的《长发公主》（Tangled）中的新弗林·赖德（Flynn Rider）。老实说，你简直体验了全部的好莱坞年轻一代。完全就是这样。全都是好莱坞年轻一代的名人，真的很疯狂。我最好的朋友，像艾莉西亚（Alicia），她……她跟你一起来的对吧？她跟我一起来的。我们把她偷渡进去了。她超级迷米洛·曼海姆。
She was like, oh my God, Nikki, Nicki, Nicki. And I was like, go up to him. And then she was like, Nikki, he just touched me to get, like, to go through the... Oh, my God. And I was like, going up to him, she was too scared. So it was basically both of us, fan-girling, you like, no, you go up to them, no, you go up to them, no, you go the whole night.
她当时说：哦天哪，尼基，尼基，尼基。我说：那你去找他呀。然后她说：尼基，他刚刚碰了我一下，为了……哦天哪。我说：你去呀。她自己又太害怕了。所以基本上我们俩都在疯狂追星，你就会说：不，你去；不，你去；不，你去。整晚都在这样。
And I'm so glad you just got to have that experience. And you were like the prayers for the health or whatever. Like, that is exactly here. I don't know if prayer is the right way, but just like the good ormonds. Whatever is out there, it was just like everything aligned. And I was so grateful. But I do feel like my nervous system was like, what the fuck has like happened today? Yeah.
我很高兴你能有这样的经历。你就像是在为健康祈祷或者别的什么。就像那确实发生了。我不知道祈祷是不是正确的词，但就像是好运。无论宇宙中有什么，一切都恰到好处地契合了。我非常感激。但我的神经系统确实有一种“今天到底发生了什么鬼”的感觉。是的。
Like, and so the day after we actually left LA and went to Malibu. be beach and I feel like I needed that to just like reground myself yeah um to get out of like LAA L.A and just be by some nature like some water and just kind of a little bit every time I'm in L.A I feel that way yeah and you were in like the most L.A situation that you could possibly find yourself truly truly the Oscars other than maybe like a coachella a pre-Cochelope oh yeah it's one of those things where it's like oh I imagine doing a carpet in America and that first carpet being like the biggest carpet ever yeah it's I feel like this is the thing I have a feeling I have this feeling a lot where I'm like fuck I'm doing all the cool
就像是这样。所以在第二天，我们实际上离开了洛杉矶，去了马里布海滩，我觉得我需要那个来让自己重新脚踏实地。是的。逃离洛杉矶，去亲近自然、亲近水，稍微平复一下。每次我在洛杉矶的时候我都会有这种感觉。是的，而且你经历的正是最典型的洛杉矶式场景。千真万确。奥斯卡，可能除了科切拉音乐节（Coachella）或者科切拉音乐节前的活动……哦，对，这就是那种感觉：哦，我幻想着在美国走红毯，而这第一次红毯竟然就是最大牌的红毯。是的。我觉得我有这种感觉，我经常有这种感觉，我会想：操，我在20多岁的时候就把所有最酷的事情都干完了……我不想慢下来，但我确实想留点东西到以后再体验。我觉得你可能也有同感。你觉得你能够积极地活在当下，并认可自己取得的成功吗？没有，因为我和你一样。我会自信地说我和你一样，然后我就会不断地想：好吧，接下来是什么？我需要进化。是的。
stuff when I'm like in my 20s like I need to I don't want to slow down but like I want to save some stuff for later I feel like you probably have the same experience do you feel like you are actively present and acknowledging the success as you have no because I'm the same as you I'm going to confidently say that I'm the same as you and then I'm constantly like okay what's next I need to like evolve yeah And I think also I just like never expected it to be to ever be anywhere near anyone famous ever. Like I was like I'm going to be like a researcher. So I still try and like always just remember myself as like a researcher and somebody who's interested in the science. Because that's the thing, isn't it?
而且我想我也从没想过自己会接近任何名。我当时觉得：我要去当研究员。所以我依然试着总是把自己当作一个研究员，一个对科学感兴趣的人。就是这样，不是吗？
When you start like even for me, when I started becoming aware of the numbers or of the certain people follow me, it was like, oh, can I put this video out because blah blah blah follows me? or blah blah blah might see this. I don't ever think about it that way. Yeah, that's what I have had to learn. You have to just post. I know. I did it for a while.
当你开始——甚至对吉我来说，当我开始意识到粉丝数字，或者注意到某些关注我的人时，我就会想：我可以发这个视频吗？因为某某某关注了我，
I think with episodes I used to really think about it. And now I'm just like, whatever. I'm just like to remember that like this is just a job and I'll have many jobs. So I'll just like do it. While I'm having fun, I'll have fun. Exactly. Whilst it's working, it works. That's the way to see it.
或者某某某可能会看到这个。我从不那样想。是的，这就是我必须去学习的。你必须直接发布。我知道。我有一段时间确实会想很多。我觉得对于单集节目，我以前真的想得很多。现在我只是觉得：随它去吧。我只想记住，这只是一份工作，我以后还会有很多工作。所以我会继续做下去。只要我还觉得开心，我就会一直开心。没错。只要它还在运作，就说明行得通。这就是看待问题的方式。
Yeah. Pride is like love. You feel it. in your heart. IR. Radio, Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists like back in the day pride. Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHartPride, Canada. Stream us on your phone, or listen now at iHartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going
是的。自豪就像爱。你能感觉得到，就在你的心中。IHeartRadio是加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括IHeart Pride Canada、你最喜欢的热门歌曲和必听派对舞曲，以及个性化和精心策划的播放列表，例如“Back in the day pride”。聚在一起，庆祝爱。随时随地，展现自豪。只需让你的智能音箱播放“IHeart Pride Canada”。在你的手机上流媒体播放，或现在就登录iHeartRadio.ca收听。当时感觉这一切仿佛会
forever I didn't think I was going to live I was terrified there was no anything inside those eyes they turned black it scared the hell out of me that was your first murder case yes sir fair to say this was the biggest case of your career yes sir rape the murder for a child just as bad as it gets i would think so people wake up i'm the woman saw the murder take place by crevette And DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief.
永远持续下去。我以为我活不成了。我吓坏了。那双眼睛里没有任何东西，它们变得漆黑一片。这把我吓得魂飞魄散。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案子吗？是的，长官。对儿童的强奸和谋杀，这是最恶劣的罪行了。我想是的。人们醒醒吧。我是目睹这起谋杀案发生的女人。罪犯是克雷维特和德皮波（Depippo）。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出任何悔意，被判处最高刑期后依然显得若无其事。我说过，我是无辜的。我会把官司打到底。
Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Lava for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda, Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Devil's Quarry》。要想无广告收听《The Devil's Quarry》并获取独家内容，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅LaVa for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特布，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb》的主持人。在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话。比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战：我曾经历过乳腺癌，后来又帮助母亲战胜乳腺癌，而那要艰难得多。许多人了解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方
you get your podcasts. is Jeterito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions.
收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb》……是奇查里托·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共存。我依然有那么多的疑问。
Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From everyday and ordinary
我们从哪里来？人死后会发生什么？你如何应对被全网抵制？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱情？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常平凡
to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is a special. spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared.
到深刻与非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是特别的、即兴的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈，脆弱感在这里流露。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标与人生教训在此分享。
All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just. Wait me, I'm going to be pressuram, but me will go to be able to be connect. The Chicharito. And Javier Al-Garito. And together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It's a crack.
生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等我，我要去……但我会去建立连接。奇查里托。我是哈维尔·阿尔·奇查里托。我和IHeartRadio一起，将让平凡变得不平凡，不平凡。保持关注。这太棒了。
Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcast. for wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. As long as there's a politics of race in America,
哇。请在IHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learning to Be Human》。有这样一件事，本不该这么复杂，那就是拆除一座种族主义雕像。还有这样一件事，本该比现在容易得多，那就是竖立一座新雕像来代替它。只要美国还存在种族政治，
there's going to be a politics of remembering the Civil War. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Lee Boulevard. Get to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence. We contain spirit.
就会存在关于如何纪念内战的政治。要去学校，我必须走罗伯特·E·李大道。要去杂货店，我必须走杰斐逊·戴维斯公园大道。如果你是一位历史学家，却漏掉了半个历史真相，那你就是在失职。我是阿基拉·休斯（Akila Hughes），《Rebel Spirit》第二季深入探讨了这两件事。抗争、政治、赢家，以及我为肯塔基州议会大厦增加一些真正配得上那面墙的东西的个人运动。我们不仅仅是我们的躯壳。我们包含着本质。我们包含着精神。
How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcasts. Speaking of which, you have launched a new podcast called Live a Little. Live a little. Live a little.
你如何表现这一点？他们只是在火上浇油，而这团火正越烧越旺。你会明白我的意思的。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Rebel Spirit》第二季。说到这里，你推出了一档新播客叫《Live a Little》。《Live a Little》。《Live a Little》。
Yeah, we were just talking about it before we started. And when did you start the podcast? So we started it, well, I started it in early December. It's been something that I've wanted to do for a very long time. I was actually supposed to start a podcast pre-COVID. And then COVID happened. And then the podcast company was like no longer a thing. And it just didn't end up happening.
是的，我们刚才在开始前还在聊这个。你是什么时候开始做这个播客的？我们开始做它……嗯，我是从12月初开始做的。这是我一直想做很久的事情。我其实应该在新冠疫情前就开始做播客的。然后疫情爆发了。接着那家播客公司就不复存在了。这事儿最终就没办成。
And also that was like then for, COVID was kind of three or four years on and off. And so by that point, my experiences, my perspective, my age had all completely changed. I'm, you know,
而且这也是因为，疫情断断续续持续了大约三四年。所以到那个时候，我的经历、我的视角、我的年龄都发生了彻底的改变。我，你知道的，
now out of school. I'm a young adult. Like my self-awareness has changed. My interests have changed, priorities, all of that stuff. So I was like, okay,
现在已经毕业了。我是一个年轻的成年人了。比如我的自我意识变了。我的兴趣变了，优先级变了，所有这些东西都变了。所以我当时想：好吧，
what does a podcast look for me now? And I'm so, someone, and I know you're the same where I would only do something if it feels right. Yeah. And I think a lot of social media
现在对我来说，播客应该是什么样子的？我是一个……而且我知道你也一样，我只在感觉对的时候才会去做某事。是的。而且我认为很多社交媒体
has become doing stuff just because, like, oh, I'll just start a podcast. You know, why not if the opportunity is there? And not to say that, you know, if you want to do that, go for it. But I knew that, like, the time had to be right for me to start when I had to have something to say. Otherwise, what is the point? I have to, like, in a lot of my life, in a great way and in a bad way, I really struggled to do anything if it doesn't feel fulfilling or purposeful.
变成了为了做而做，就像：哦，我只要开个播客就行了。你知道，如果有机会的话为什么不呢？并不是说如果你想这么做，就去追求它。但我知道，对我来说时机必须合适，当我必须有话要说的时候才能开始。否则有什么意义呢？我必须……在我的很多生活中，不管是好是坏，如果一件事不能让我感到充实或有目的性，我真的很难去推进它。
And that can almost hit me, you know, hit me in the bad way because I'm then, like, searching for that in every single thing I do. And then I'm like, Nikki, this can just be a thing. It doesn't need to be like this massive impact or this massive purposeful thing or fulfill you in a certain way. Obviously everything should hopefully fulfill you in life that you do. But for me, the podcast just felt like it was right. And I feel like I was so, again, with all the short form stuff, all the you need to hook this, you need to optimize that. Like we were talking about, I needed something that felt like a breath of fresh air.
这几乎会（你知道的）给我带来负面的影响，因为我会在我做的每一件事中去寻找那种目的。然后我会想：尼基，这可以只是一件普通的事。它不需要带来多么巨大的影响力，不需要有什么伟大的目的，也不需要以某种特定方式让你感到充实。当然，你生活中做的每件事都应该能带给你充实感。但对我来说，这个播客就是让我觉得一切都对了。我觉得我太……同样地，面对所有短视频内容，所有的“你需要吸引眼球”、“你需要优化这个”。就像我们刚才聊的那样，我需要一些能带来呼吸感的东西。
I needed something that felt like an escapism back to kind of my YouTube roots where I just sit and talk to a camera. Yeah. And it's funny. it's like as soon as you have a microphone and a camera in front of you, the honesty is just coming out. I don't know what it is. It unlocked something in you. And so for me, Live a little was from an idea of a lot of my life, I have felt very alone and I've not had that friend that gets me.
我需要一些能让我逃离现实、回归我YouTube初心感的东西，在那里我只是坐着和镜头聊天。是的。这很有趣，就像一旦你面前摆着麦克风和镜头，诚实就会自然而然地流露出来。我不知道为什么，它解锁了你内心深处的某个东西。所以对我来说，《Live a Little》这个节目的灵感来自于我生活中的很多时候，我曾感到非常孤独，我没有那个真正懂我的朋友。
And there's been so many things I ruminate over and I've had no one to discuss them with. So it's my idea of like the listener is the friend. And we can be that for each other. It's a 3am chat you have at a sleepover or the call you have with your friend or the deep introspective chats or the like cringe chats or the, like, cringe chats or the, embarrassing conversations. And so I've done episodes about like romanticising what alone time looks like and how I've spent a lot of my time alone. So I saw it as a negative thing and how to make it more purposeful now. You know, learning to play again as an adult like we were talking about
有很多事情我在心里反刍，却没有人可以讨论。所以我的设想是：听众就是朋友。我们可以成为彼此的朋友。这是你在睡衣派对上凌晨3点进行的畅谈，或者是你和朋友打的电话，或者是那种深入的内省聊天，或者尴尬的、让人脚趾抠地的对话。所以我也做了一些关于浪漫化独处时光、以及我如何度过大量独处时光的节目。我曾将其视为一件消极的事，而现在是如何让它更有意义。比如作为一个成年人重新学习如何玩耍（就像我们刚才聊的），
and like what that looks like because adults, you know, we forget that playtime is so important even more. So Live a Little was the idea that I've lived so much life in the things I've done that we've talked about, you know, as like the youngest person to get an BAFTA and I got an Emmy when I was like 15, these crazy things. But then I've lived so much little life in my childhood. I didn't really have one from six years old at all. I became like 60 when I was six years old. And, you know, just normal life experiences or independence I don't have. So it's that idea. But equally, just life is short and life can be so serious at times. So we all need to just live a little because tomorrow's not promised. So it's just exploratory. It's supposed to feel comforting. A lot of the
那是什么样子的，因为成年人，你知道的，我们忘记了玩耍的时间是如此重要，甚至更加重要。所以《Live a Little》的理念是，在我所经历的事情中，我经历了如此多“宏大”的人生，正如我们所谈到的，比如成为获得英国电影学院奖（BAFTA）最年轻的人，我15岁时就得了艾美奖，这些疯狂的事情。但与此同时，我在童年时期却错过了很多“微小”的生活。我从六岁起就根本没有过真正意义上的童年。我在六岁时就变得像60岁一样。而且，你知道的，正常的生活经历或独立性我都没有。所以这就是那个概念。但同样地，生活很短，而且有时生活会非常严肃。所以我们都需要“Live a Little”（及时行乐/享受生活），因为明天并不能保证一定会到来。所以它只是探索性的。它应该让人感到宽慰。我请来的很多
people I have on. It's like not really about I've had actors on, advocates on, um, musicians on, um, and activists. And it's mainly about, of course, what they do, but who they are. Outside of what they do. It's like meant to humanize people because I think so much of life now is either people dehumanizing one another, social media can feel, you know, so unrealistic and so comparative at times. It's like, let me bring you back to us. So we'll like sit on the floor. I take my shoes off. And it's like, you know, it's very rare you see like actors in that kind of setting. Yeah. Like shoes off, like cross-legged on a like a little sofa thing. Yeah, just chilling. It's really good. You should go and watch it. So I should listen to it. With that in mind,
嘉宾……其实并不是那么聚焦于成就，我请过演员、倡导者、音乐家、活动家。这主要关乎他们所做的事情，但更是关乎他们是谁。在他们所做的工作之外的真实自我。它旨在让人们回归人性，因为我认为现在生活中的很多事情要么是人们在互相剥夺人性，社交媒体有时会让人觉得（你知道的）那么不切实际，充满了攀比。这就好比：让我把你带回我们真实的自我。所以我们会坐在地板上。我脱掉鞋子。而且，你知道的，你很少看到演员在这种环境里。是的。脱掉鞋子，盘腿坐在一个小沙发上。是的，就是很放松。真的很好。你应该去看看。所以我应该去听听看。考虑到这一点，
what is my final question? What's something really big that you want to achieve in the next 10 years? What a question. I mean, there's so many things. I think I would really love to have more, based on what we've been talking about, more stability, like personally in my life and in my job. and feel really content and stay safe and stable with it. That's something I'm still kind of, you know, I feel like I'm constantly peddling on a bike and I need to just figure out, like, what the baseline is and hopefully be able to roll with that.
我的最后一个问题是什么？在接下来的十年里，你真正想实现的一件大事是什么？真是个好问题。我的意思是，有太多事情了。结合我们之前讨论的，我觉得我真的希望能获得更多稳定感，比如我个人生活和工作上的稳定。并且感到真正的满足，在其中保持安全和稳定。这仍然是我一直在努力的事情，你知道的，我感觉自己就像一直在骑自行车，我需要弄清楚基准线在哪里，并希望能顺其自然地生活。
But outside of that, I think it's, you know, with all of the facial advocacy I do, we still have such a long way to go. It's incredible that I've been able to be in spaces that have, you know, in the past not been that inclusive, aka the Oscars, can film festival. I could go on. And so for me, a massive part of what I do is the advocacy and it's the showing up.
但除此之外，我认为，你知道的，凭借我所做的所有面部平权发声，我们还有很长的路要走。我能进入一些过去并不那么具包容性的空间，这真是不可思议，也就是奥斯卡、戛纳电影节，我还可以列举更多。所以对我来说，我所做的事情中很重要的一部分就是倡导，以及出席这些场合。
I always say that one of my biggest dreams is to work with like a game or like a toy, like a Barbie and create a Barbie with like a facial difference. Oh my God, let's make that fucking happen. I know. That's my dream. That is such a great dream. I've been like talking about it for so long. I'm like Barbie. They just did an autistic Barbie.
我总是说，我最大的梦想之一就是与某个游戏或玩具合作，比如芭比娃娃，创造一个带有面部差异的芭比。哦天哪，我们一定要把它实现。我懂。那是我的梦想。这真是一个伟大的梦想。我谈论这个已经很久了。我当时就想，是芭比。他们刚刚推出了一个自闭症芭比。
It's amazing. And I feel like last year they did another. They did like a diabetic barbie. Yeah, diabetic. Syndrome Barbie. So many different ones, a blind Barbie. So I feel like, of course, every facial difference is different. That's the whole point.
这太棒了。我觉得去年他们又做了一个。他们做了一个糖尿病芭比。是的，糖尿病患者。综合征芭比。有那么多不同的版本，还有一个盲人芭比。所以我觉得，当然，每个人的面部差异都是不同的。这正是重点所在。
But I feel like it would be so incredibly special. I never saw myself in anything growing up. And it's not to say that only people with facial differences should play with this Barbie, but it's just a Barbie. And I think so much of kids learning comes from play and comes from exposure to things. And toys are such an incredible way to teach kids about things before you can verbalize. them and make sense of them through words. And so for me, that would be incredible, like, either with a Barbie or a Lego or, like, maybe
但我感觉这将是无比特别的。我从小到大从未在任何事物中看到过自己的影子。这并不是说只有有面部差异的人才能玩这个芭比，它只是一个芭比。我认为孩子们的很大一部分学习来自于玩耍，来自于对事物的接触。玩具是向孩子们传授事物的一种不可思议的方式，甚至在你用语言表达它们并用言语理解它们之前就可以。所以对我来说，那将是不可思议的，无论是芭比娃娃、乐高，还是可能
it's like a Sim character, Sims character that has a facial difference. Like, that is my dream is to enter other spaces, which just make it feel so, like, mainstream and normal. So I think that would be an incredible thing. I would love to continue doing documentarial work. Like, in my past, I did, like, a lot of documentaries about my life and presenting. So I would love to continue doing that. ever since I was little, like, I mean, I'm definitely not like a, look at me, like I'm not that kind of person.
比如一个模拟市民的角色，也就是有面部差异的模拟市民角色。我的梦想就是进入其他领域，让这一切感觉非常主流和正常。所以我认为那将是一件了不起的事情。我很乐意继续做纪录片工作。就像过去一样，我拍了很多关于我的生活和主持的纪录片。所以我很乐意继续这样做。自从我小时候以来，我的意思是，我绝对不是那种“快看我”的人，我不是那种人。
I am pretty introverted, but ever since I was little, I loved pretending I was on TV and I loved, like, that world and I loved, it was my escapism, you know, because I didn't see myself in toys or TV, so that would be my world in which I existed. So I'd love to continue with that. And hopefully with what I can do, there's power in numbers. So hopefully the more I can do, the more it opens the door to other people being able to do it. I mean, even at the Met Gala this year, there was like a lot more people with disabilities there, which was so incredible to see. I saw who was the girl who was in the Hunger Games, sleeping. I'm terrible with names. So am I. Okay, well, look it up. She was the first of a wheelchair user to attend the Met Gala.
我相当内向，但从小我就喜欢假装自己上了电视，我喜欢那种世界，我喜欢，那是我的逃避现实的方式，你知道的，因为我在玩具或电视里看不到自己，所以那是我的世界。所以我很乐意继续这样做。希望通过我所能做的，众人拾柴火焰高。所以希望我做得越多，就越能为其他人敞开大门。我的意思是，甚至在今年的Met Gala上，那里有更多残疾人，看到这一幕真是太不可思议了。我看到那个女孩是谁，演《饥饿游戏》的那个，在睡觉的那个。我记名字太差了。我也是。好吧，查一下。她是第一位参加Met Gala的轮椅使用者。
That's what I mean. And I was like, that's fucking cool. And also kind of crazy, that's the first person. I know, right. I read that and I was a bit like, great, but also what? Yeah, I was like, that's, that's, that's. quite insane. Yeah.
这就是我的意思。当时我就想，太酷了。同时也觉得有点疯狂，她竟然是第一个人。我懂的，真的。我读到那个消息时有点觉得，太棒了，但同时又想，什么？是的，我当时觉得，这，这，这真是太疯狂了。是的。
It was even like, I would touch on it quickly, but last September I walked in Paris Fashion Week for a brand. And it was like one of the first times that there's been someone with a proper facial difference walking show in Paris Fashion Week. And I closed it and Vogue runway was like, Nicky was the best part of the show. Oh my God. It was craziness.
甚至就像，我简单提一下，去年九月我为某个品牌在巴黎时装周上走秀。这是有面部差异的人第一次在巴黎时装周的秀场上走秀。而且我是压轴出场，Vogue runway还说，Nicky是秀场上最棒的部分。哦天哪。太疯狂了。
What? That's so cool. But again, it's like so incredible, but also. why is this good thing, you know? Yeah. So it's just, I want things to just feel normalized. And I think sometimes people that don't have facial differences or differences think that we want to be like having special treatment.
什么？太酷了。但话说回来，这既不可思议，但又为什么这是一件好事呢，你知道吗？是的。所以这只是，我希望一切都能恢复正常。我认为有时没有面部差异或差异的人会认为我们想要得到特殊对待。
But it's honestly, we just want to be able to be in the room without it feeling either tokenized or like we've had to like kick down 10 doors while someone else has kicked down or just slightly open one to get through it. Also, it's so funny to me that it's like, you guys want special treatment. And it's like, well, we just aren't quality. Yeah. It's also just like, but you guys have all the. the treatment. So like, aren't you getting the special treatment? Like people like me would have
但老实说，我们只是希望能够进入这个房间，而不觉得这是一种象征性的施舍，或者感觉我们必须踢倒10扇门，而别人只要稍微推开一扇门就能通过。另外，我觉得很有趣的是，你们觉得我们想要特殊对待。而事实是，我们只是没有受到公平对待。是的。这就好比，你们享受了所有的特权。所以难道不是你们在享受特殊对待吗？像我这样的人会
not people like me. People though like have walked fashion runways like do you know what I mean? That's it. Asking for one small thing is not special treatment. No. 99% goes to what I'm and it really wouldn't take that much. Yeah, exactly. Things to, you know, change. Yeah. But it's people wanting to make the change. Yeah. Yeah. I want to walk a fashion runway. Oh my God. Let's do it. We do it together. I think I'll leave it to you. I think you're the professional. I think you're... Hey, maybe in 10 years. You never know. Yeah, we'll see. Yeah, we'll see.
不是像我这样的人。不过是那些走过时装秀的人，你知道我的意思吗？就是这样。要求一件小事并不是特殊对待。不。99%的资源都落在了我身上，其实根本不需要付出那么多。是的， exatamente。事情要发生改变，你知道的。是的。但这需要人们想要做出改变。是的。是的。我想走时装秀。哦天哪。我们走吧。我们一起走。我想我还是留给你吧。我想你是专业的。我想你是……嘿，也许十年后。你永远不知道。是的，我们走着瞧。是的，我们走着瞧。
We'll see. Well, thank you so much for coming on the podcast. Did you enjoy our chat? I have loved this. This has felt like therapy. Oh, I'm so bad. In the best way. Oh, good. Like, it's felt so, like, cathartic and I could talk to you for hours. I just know our brains work in really similar ways. Oh, my God. It's actually been hard to not be like, oh. Yeah, I know.
我们走着瞧。非常感谢你来参加这个播客。你喜欢我们的聊天吗？我太喜欢了。这感觉就像在做心理治疗。哦，我真糟糕。以最好的方式。哦，太好了。感觉非常宣泄，我可以和你聊上几个小时。我只是知道我们的思维方式非常相似。哦，天哪。事实上，克制自己不去说“哦”真的很难。是的，我知道。
I know. I'm like jumping in, like, as if we're all friends. I'm always like that was like my pod. When I'm talking to people, I'm like, rain it in, rain it in, rain it in. So like, let them finish. Yeah. And I also have this terrible habit where I'm like, mm-hmm. Same.
我知道。我一直在插话，就好像我们都是朋友一样。我总是觉得，就像在我的播客里一样。当我和别人说话时，我总是对自己说，收敛一点，收敛一点，收敛一点！所以，让他们把话说完。是的。而且我还有一个糟糕的习惯，就是会说“嗯嗯”。我也是。
Because you want to, like, show them you're acknowledging. Yeah. But then you also like, or I'll be like, yeah, yeah, yeah. And I'm like, just sorry. I don't know. People always leave comments on my episodes being like, shut up. And I'm like, I know, but I'm just so in, like, because that's what you would do if like it was your friends.
因为你想向他们表明你在倾听。是的。但随后你也会，或者我会说，对，对，对。然后我想，对不起，我不知道。人们总是在我的节目下方留言说，闭嘴吧。然后我想，我知道，但我太投入了，因为如果这是和你的朋友聊天，你就会这么做。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Well, I'm so glad. I'm going to leave links to live a little everything else. If you enjoyed the chat, even if you didn't, go and follow Nikki anyways, because she has amazing things to say. Her videos are also just cool. Thank you.
对，完全正确。好吧，我太高兴了。我会把链接留在简介里，还有其他所有内容。如果你喜欢这次聊天，即使不喜欢，也去关注Nicky吧，因为她有很多精彩的观点要分享。她的视频也很酷。谢谢。
You should share behind the scenes of just like amazing things that you're doing in life and also the every day. Don't forget that this episode is also on Netflix. If you want to go and check it out, you can also follow us on Instagram at That Psychology podcast. And as Nikki mentioned in the beginning, we have a substack. Also, the psychology of your 20s, which you can go and check out right now. Thank you for listening.
你应该分享你生活中正在做的那些精彩事情的幕后花絮，以及日常生活。别忘了本期节目也在Netflix上线了。如果你想去看看，你也可以在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology podcast。正如Nicky在开头提到的，我们有一个Substack。还有《The Psychology of Your 20s》，你现在就可以去看看。感谢收听。
Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse,
注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快就会再聊。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变黑了。吓死我了。恶魔，醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹克里瓦克和德皮波行凶的人。安东尼·德皮波毫无悔意，
appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby.
在被判处最高刑期后显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我至死也不会承认。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Bone Valley播客的《The Devil's Quarry》。快乐至关重要，但它也很难捉摸。不过现在，有一个全新且令人兴奋的方式来开始你通往更快乐生活旅程的新起点。Joy 101。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。
If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning
如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中聊天。打开免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由霍达·科特比主持的Joy 101由CVS呈现。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天我仍在学习
how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest, conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was.
如何与问题、错误、人际关系以及自出生以来的各种情绪共存。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每一件事都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。只有关于活着意味着什么的坦诚对话。我是哈维尔·埃尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯，请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Learning to Be Human。你的丈夫并不是你想象的那样。你的身体也不是你所认为的那样。
Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets. He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. and that was the last time I saw him. Listen to season 14 of Family Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
你的身份是由一段秘密历史塑造的。我是丹妮·夏皮罗。这些只是我将在《家庭秘密》第十四季中探讨的众多惊人故事中的一部分。他一把把我推开，说，让开。然后他走到前门，跳上一辆车开走了，那是我最后一次见到他。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《家庭秘密》第十四季，
or wherever you get your podcasts. For years, the Un-House have been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Weed-N-Haus is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created the show
多年来，在主流媒体中，无家可归者一直被呈现为一个铁板一块的整体。Weed-N-Haus是一个正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，我创立了这个节目
while I was Un-Housed on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast. The only podcast that shares Un-House stories and news from the unhoused perspective.
当时我正流落洛杉矶的街头。我们已经成长为一个两度获得威比奖的播客。这是唯一一个分享无家可归者故事以及来自无家可归者视角的新闻的播客。
Listen to Weythian House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Weythian House。这是一个IHeart播客，保证由真人制作。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。